- Welcome to the second
annual "Trash Taste Awards."
(men cheering)
(upbeat music)
- Perfect.
- My man!
- Nailed it!
- Glass for you.
- Wow.
One take wonder right there.
- A glass for me.
- It had to be a one
take wonder, you know?
- We've only one bottle of champagne.
- Hold on, hold on,
before we get criticism,
we have to undo our jackets
'cause we're sitting down,
'cause someone got really angry last year.
I just wanted to show off the suit.
Let's do a drip appreciation real quick.
- Yeah, unlike last year,
I actually am wearing a Jojo suit.
Oh, Joey, you actually
wore pants this time.
- I wore pants this time.
- All right, yeah.
- No one will ever know I
didn't wear pants last time.
- Wearing the Giorno suit
with a black shirt this time,
mixing it up, feeling spicy.
All right, let's undo it.
- Got the Bucciarati suit.
Wait, 'cause I've never worn
a double breasted suit normally.
Do you still unbutton it or-
- [Producer] It's appropriate to button
your double breasted suit.
- Yeah yeah, I thought, I
thought so, I thought so.
- Okay, so Connor and I will
just undo it, that's fine.
- I'll keep it buttoned up.
- All right, all right.
Whatever, whatever.
- [Garnt] 'Cause I got-
- I went with the Mista tie this time.
I'm changing it up a little bit.
- Okay, nice.
- Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Looking good, looking good.
Well, let's try the champagne then.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, go for it.
- Before we I guess,
jerk ourselves off and.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(men chuckling)
- For the next,
isn't that just a regular
"Trash Taste" episode?
- True, true.
- That's no different
from what we normally do.
- True, true, true.
- But ladies and gentlemen,
this is episode 100.
- Yes.
- Wow.
- We've hit the big three digits.
- 102 years of "Trash Taste."
- 102!
102 years?
- I haven't had this much head
since I went to a Jojo meet up, bro.
- Shut the fuck.
- Oh my God.
This is like back of the
Walmart head, now that's.
- This isn't a fucking beer, Connor.
- More please, more please.
- It's champagne okay?
- More please, more, more.
- It is meant to be bubbly.
- Champagan.
- Like if we were truly-
- There we go, look at that.
What a good pour, wow.
- If we were truly cultured,
we'd be drinking out of champagne glasses.
I will say that these are not-
- No, 'cause we don't have
Trash Taste champagne glasses.
We just have Trash Taste glasses.
- Unfortunately not, unfortunately not.
So we're just drinking out
of normal wine glasses.
- By the way, Wendy,
thank you for the glasses.
- Thank you very much for the glasses.
- Well, cheers, boys.
- Cheers boys, to 100 episodes.
- 100 episodes.
- Woo!
(crew clapping)
- Wow, we are literally
in triple digit episodes.
My God.
- That's scary isn't it?
- Wow.
- That's gone so quickly.
Joe, do you know what I forgot about?
- [Joey] Hm?
- I forgot that we moved
to a new studio this year.
- Yeah. Tell that-
- That happened this year?
- Huh?
- Happened this year?
- Well, I mean.
- Within the last year.
- The first award show was at
the last episode, last studio.
- Oh it was, yeah, yeah.
- Last year.
- Last year, yeah.
And we only had like four or five episodes
after the "Trash Taste
Awards," before the move.
- Yeah, that's right.
It wasn't long after, wasn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, but it didn't feel that way,
because the last episode
we filmed in the old studio
was the "Trash Taste Awards", right?
- I believe so?
- Probably.
- I don't know.
- It's canon now.
It's canon now, that is it.
- No one can confirm that everyone's real.
- I think because we tried to
delay it as much as possible
to have the awards as close
to episode 50 as possible,
even though we'd already
secured our new studio
and we needed to record a bunch,
record a bunch of episodes
to make sure that we had enough episodes
to cover us for the move.
So yeah, the "Trash Taste"
episode was the last episode.
- Yeah, that's, yeah, yeah.
I meant to say that.
- So yeah, how do you
boys feel about, this?
- Have you ever been on a podcast
that made it past like 50 episodes?
I've not.
No, I've never been on anything
that made it past 50 episodes.
- Have you ever been on
a podcast before, period?
- [Joey] Before, yeah.
- I had my own podcast
that lasted two episodes.
- I had my own radio show that lasted, 30?
- Oh you had the-
- The anime show, yeah.
- "The Joey Show."
- How many episodes?
- I think I did like 30 episodes of that.
- How many episodes of
"PodTaku" did that end at?
- You were at like 20 or 14 something?
No.
- I don't know.
It was way more than that.
- It was more than 20.
- It was way more than that.
- You wanna beat your old self?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You don't get another
chance to start again though,
Garnt, if you do.
- The only one who can defeat me is me.
- Exactly, right?
Exactly. How many, how
many episodes of "PodTaku"?
- I think you probably got to like,
maybe like a little under 50, maybe?
- Because the thing is,
there was like two versions.
There was like "PodTaku" and "J-Taku,"
so it was, like that went on for-
- This is Garnt lore.
- Yeah, this is Garnt lore.
That went on for like four years though.
But it was four years, not as
consistent as "Trash Taste,"
so it is a very, very different vibe.
- I think-
- Yes, Ashley?
- [Ashley] You have 76 videos.
I don't know if that's 76 episodes.
- That's 76 episodes then.
We've already beaten it.
- Aye, new PB, let's go.
- Aye!
New PB, new PB!
- I mean, to be honest,
it's a miracle that a podcast
even lasts over 100 episodes.
- True.
- I feel.
I don't know that many.
- I feel like over 50 episodes.
- Oh yeah, honestly.
- I think it's pretty impressive
that we have uploaded every single week.
- We've never missed a week.
- We've never missed a an episode.
We've never had to delay it a day.
- Please don't let that be polly-
- [Garnt] You know what I will say?
- Even if it isn't, I think
it's impressive we got to 100.
- Yeah.
- You know what I will say?
Because like most other podcasts,
they go on for like an hour per episode.
We've done two hour episodes bar like,
I think two or something,
for 100 episodes.
- That's two, that's like
roughly 200 hours of talking.
- Yeah.
- Too long.
Too long.
- At which point do we make
as much content hours as "One Piece?"
That's the next goal.
That is the next goal I want.
- I want it to get to the point
where there will be people
out there who will go,
"What takes longer to finish, One Piece,"
"or Trash Taste?"
- or "Trash Taste!"
- I mean, we're getting
there, we're getting there.
- Yeah, but thinking about it, a lot has,
we've done a lot this year,
because we've obviously moved studio,
and I think "Trash Taste After Dark"
has just been like a massive
thing that we started.
- Oh yeah.
- Yes.
- I mean, I remember last year
we had like three streams or something
that we streamed because
we kind of felt like it.
- I think we did four or five episodes
of "Trash Taste After Dark",
but then obviously they
weren't so much like,
you know, like a Twitch
show as more, just like a,
you know, a "Trash Taste" after birth,
you know, type of thing.
- After birth.
- Or after-
(Garnt laughing)
You know, after thought, you know?
(Garnt grunting)
- Yeah, you know,
just like squeezing that last little bit
from like the main episode
into like a stream, you know?
- I think it's really cool
we have like a different
set for the live streams
and the show, the normal podcast.
You know, I think it offers
a different kind of
"Trash Taste" experience
if that's what they're looking for.
- Well, I mean the old
episode was just the same one.
- Yeah.
- Because like,
I think the issue with the
old "Trash Taste" streams
is that it was just more "Trash Taste."
- It just looked like "Trash Taste."
- Yeah, it was, it looked
like "Trash Taste."
We did the same things as
we do on "Trash Taste,"
we just talked, just with a live chat.
But I feel like there's definitely,
we've definitely been able to distinct,
make "Trash Taste After
Dark" more distinctive,
not only with the set, but
with what we do in it as well.
'Cause we have, we get to
do like play some fun games.
We get to do some fun stuff
in "Trash Taste After Dark."
- I mean, could you have imagined
trying to do the 24 hour
stream in the old office?
- No.
- Oh my God, oh my God.
- That would've sucked ass.
- Pretty sure Ashley would quit.
Life, if he told us.
- Well, you know it's good
because people are starting to comment,
"Oh, well I like "Trash Taste After Dark""
"more than "Trash Taste" now."
So that means that we're doing a good job.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Doing a good job.
- That's like weirdly flattering, right?
- Yeah, it is, isn't it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- To be like, "Oh, we beat ourselves."
(men laughing)
- I mean, if you prefer
"Trash Taste After Dark",
that's like all good.
That's still "Trash Taste," baby.
- Still Trash, that's still us.
- Yeah, it's still us.
- We're okay with it.
- So what is the "Trash Taste Awards"?
Vsauce music. All right, so.
- Explain it.
- To people who don't know
what the "Trash Taste Awards" are,
it's something that we've done once before
and we liked it so much
that we're doing it again.
Basically-
- We're gonna try and do it annually.
- Yeah, basically, you know,
there's a lot of moments in "Trash Taste"
that not everyone can keep up with.
There's a lot of-
- Lot of content.
- A lot of arguments, a lot
of dumb shit that happens.
Maybe a screenshot you recognize.
You're like, "Where, which
episode's that from?"
So basically this is an award show
to kind of have you, the viewers,
vote on your favorite moments
of the last 50 episodes of "Trash Taste."
Most, I guess, iconic moments.
The dumbest screenshots,
the baddest takes,
and when we complain about America.
- [Joey] It's basically-
- It's basically just a
highlight reel for you guys
because there's a lot of
"Trash Taste" content now.
Not only on one channel,
on multiple channels.
- This is basically
"Inside joke, the episode."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Essentially.
- And it's your chance to catch up
to all of the weird and wonderful moments
that you may have missed over the year.
- So if there's like a moment, you know,
you see during the "Trash Taste
Awards" where you're like,
"Ooh, I wanna know what that's
like, you know, in context."
Or "I wanna see the full scope of it."
Then you can go back and check
it out and catch up on it.
- And for us, we just
get to suck own dicks.
That's-
- Like a true Jojo fan.
- That's why we're wearing
the Jojo suits, right?
That is why we're wearing the Jojo suits.
- I guess we are, I guess we are.
- Don't deny.
You don't deny, we are.
- This is literally like the Obama image
with just like the medal, right?
- Giving the award to yourself.
- "Oh, look at all these awards."
- So we have a bunch of categories.
Should we tell everyone
what the categories are?
- Yeah.
- Just go through them all?
- Do you have a slide
for that, Ashley, or no?
- I think we.
- I do.
- Oh really?
- [Ashley] I do have a slide for that.
- Oh, brilliant.
- To go into this one.
- Ashley, Ashley planned ahead for us.
- [Joey] Although where's?
- By the way, it's spelled Awardw.
That's an inside joke, again.
I gotta explain that 'cause this is.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause last time I did the post calling
for ideas for the awards,
I did a typo.
- On the Reddit, yeah.
- Yeah, I did a typo, so
that's why it has a W.
It's not that funny, but
it kinda stuck around.
I don't know why.
- It's also because we're giving
ourselves a W, that's why.
- Yeah, I guess we are. I had to make a W.
- I know, it was the Connor thing.
We're monkeys, okay?
- All right, all right, all right.
- You know one W in award wasn't enough.
I needed another dub.
- Joey, if there's one
"Trash Taste" is not about,
it's not about getting W's, Joey,
'cause none of us get W's.
- It's like two W's cancel each other out.
- Yeah.
- It's all L's as we're about to find out
on this award, man.
- All right, let's go to the first slide.
Just going over the nominations, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, okay.
- [Connor] So we have
hot take of the year.
That's number one?
We're just going out the
gate with the strong?
- We're going straight on, man.
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
- You guys are in for a treat.
We have best out of context clip.
Best screen grab of the year.
Most degenerate moment.
Most salty moment.
- One of us.
- Best monkey moment,
named after me, I suppose.
- Yes.
- [Connor] The best
story, the biggest clown,
the biggest Chad, the best nickname,
the best complaining about America moment.
- Of course.
- Yes.
- 'Cause God knows there's enough of that.
- Sorry, Americans, sorry.
- Best meme.
The fans, "They actually
talked about, anime award."
- That's a new one, right?
- That is a new one, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, we didn't have that last year.
- [Connor] Best tangent,
best drip, laziest drip.
Best rant, best argument, worst food take.
Best poop moment, I think that's new.
- Yeah, that's definitely new.
- [Connor] Most privileged moment.
That's new.
- That's new.
- [Connor] The "I made
it the fuck up award."
Which is new.
- What's your source?
- [Connor] Best "Trash
Taste After Dark" episode,
which is new as well.
- Hell yeah.
- [Connor] Dumbest quiz
answer, which is new as well.
Moment of the year,
and the best "Trash Taste"
episode of the year,
according to you guys.
- Yeah, so you guys voted on this
and you guys gave us
the nominations as well.
- So we might judge your taste.
- Yeah.
- Your trash taste.
- So if you wanna blame
anyone, you can blame yourself.
- So if we get to a certain
point, you're like, "No, no."
"The best one was definitely
not in these nominations."
That's on you, not us.
- So, I mean, I wouldn't blame you guys,
'cause there's a lot of content
that happened this past year.
And even we were making the content
and we don't remember hardly anything
that happened this year.
- This is gonna be like a nice
trip down memory lane, right?
- Yeah.
- Because I guarantee there's
gonna be a bunch of moments
where like, "Oh, that got nominated?"
- Yeah, I do remember looking
at the nominations list
and there was like one moment
that I remember happened
that I think deserves to be
represented somewhere here.
So I'm gonna just gonna shout it out now,
because it was actually at the old studio,
which is why I think it got passed over.
- [Joey] Oh, I see.
- But it was the moment
where the confusion happened
when Connor was talking about
taking the fridge.
- The fridge?
- Oh, from my house?
- Yeah, from your house.
And like, that was the only
moment I remember post.
I was like, "Oh, damn."
If only I remembered earlier,
I could have told Ashley
to put it in, but like,
Mudon, you can play the clip,
because I just wanna give
it a quick shout out.
'Cause it's one of my
favorite moments of the year.
- That is a good clip.
- Finally getting rid
of my laundry machine.
Washing machine.
- Yeah, we're getting rid of ours as well.
- Covered in, my cockroach infested one.
- Oh shit, that one.
- Oh, you still have that one?
- Yeah, I still have that one, okay?
- Okay.
- I still have it.
- I mean, he cleaned it up though.
- I thought you bought a new one.
- He cleaned it up, right?
- Yeah, I did clean it up, but,
I mean, I don't know what's been in there.
So it is nice to get rid
of it and get a new one.
- Get something nice, you can afford it.
- Treat my, I'm taking the
old one from this studio.
- Are you?
- Yeah.
- Wait, what?
- Are you actually?
'Cause it's like the
equal amounts of confusion
where Connor says a story
about taking the fridge
and we all think,
all three of us thought
three different things.
- I thought the right
thing, it's my story.
- You just phrased it
in a way that was like,
"What the fuck?"
- 'Cause it was using-
- [Connor] Right, right.
- Using descripts, like that and it,
and we were like saying, "Oh,
you took it from this place?"
And then, yeah, yeah.
And it was just like the
perfect chaotic moment.
And I remember like-
- Sorry.
- I remember one of my favorite parts
was the subreddit breaking
down how this happened,
and it was like.
- It was like a "JCS
Criminal Psychology" episode.
on how communication
fails between primates.
- Unfortunately it seems
many people forgot that
because it was actually at the start.
- Honorable mention.
- So you'll notice,
there's like recency
bias with some of these.
- Of course.
- We don't know who's won yet.
We are totally in the dark,
but we know the nominations obviously.
So yeah, it's gonna be interesting
to see what people chose.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, I'm excited for it.
- Shall we just jump straight into it?
- We have a lot of stuff.
We have a lot of-
- Hot take of the year.
Not as hot as your mum though.
- Okay, I have this.
- You don't know that.
My mum is a beautiful woman.
How dare you.
- Would you describe your mum as hot?
- No.
- Okay then, I guess it's solved then.
- All right, let's see.
What are the nominations?
- So, I mean,
I believe we're going
right out of the gates
with hot take of the year.
Because here's the thing, right?
I dunno what counts as like a hot take,
is it like a bad take
or controversial take?
- Mm.
- I think it's a bit of both, you know?
I think if you have a take
that 95% people disagree with,
that could get you in
the hot take category.
- Yeah, all right.
- I think if you also-
- That's just a bad take, right?
- I mean, you know, people,
you know, I'm sure when,
whenever they figured
out the earth was flat,
I'm sure that was a hot take
at the time. I'm joking.
- Is a bad take just-
- You mean when they figured
out the world was round.
- Is a hot take just not
a bad take with reasons?
If you think about.
- Listen, listen.
People-
- That's all a hot take is.
- People have been shunned in the past
and then they turned out to be right.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So a hot take doesn't mean you're right.
It just means you're going
against the consensus.
- Well, let's say what
the nominations are.
So we have "90% of bread tastes the same."
That's a, that's a Garnt take right there.
- Okay, I have to ask,
do you stand by this
statement to this day?
- Um.
What did I say in the episode?
I can't, I can't-
- The general sentiment
of this, of the take,
do you stand by it?
- I can't, I don't believe
all bread tastes the same.
- But 90%.
- But.
- There's 10% that
tastes different, right?
- So I, 'cause I believe,
okay, here's the thing.
I remember the argument we had
was because Connor was saying
"I would eat bread as a main course."
And I was like, "I can't
eat bread as a main course."
I need a supplement with the bread
in order to enjoy it, right?
It's a nice snack, but it's
like not a meal, you know?
And that's where I let
out this outrageous line.
- [Joey] And then another food take here
from Connor this time.
"Food poisoning is not an illness."
Do you stand by that?
- Absolutely.
I think it was a case of,
I think it was a case of good point,
terrible execution on my part,
which is Connor syndrome at this point.
- Yeah, that's just-
- Which is an actual valid take
that I just described so poorly
that people don't wanna agree with me.
- Right.
- And then on the subreddit
and Twitter and stuff,
people have to fix my explanation.
- Of course.
- So that often happens.
- I mean, they have to fix
explanations with all of us.
- I still stand by this,
this general sentiment is still,
you know, correct I think.
- Okay, and then one from me this time.
""JuJutsu Kaisen" was okay."
- This is really that outrageous?
- I mean, I don't think it was, but.
- I hope this one wins. (laughs)
I, I really, really want
""JuJutsu Kaisen" was okay"
to win hot take of the year.
- You know what?
I kind of agree, to be honest.
- I'm like, out of everything here,
we have some outrageous takes,
but like I want that one to win,
just because, just to be
like Shonen fans be like,
"Hot take of the year."
"90% of bread of it is all the same?"
No.
- This is the only time when Shonen fans
are actually gonna come together
to like cooperate on something.
- I really hope so, I really hope so.
- Don't stop right there,
'cause the next one is
"86 was bad," by me.
I stand by that, obviously.
- Two of them are anime takes.
- This was the, one of the
biggest meltdowns I'd ever seen
from a "Trash Taste" episode.
People lost their shit when I said this.
People were like in tears.
- It reminded me that our
"Trash Taste" episode,
our "Trash Taste" viewers
were also anime fans,
which I forgot for the longest time.
- [Joey] I almost forgot, yeah.
- I forgot for the longest
time that you know?
- [Joey] I almost forgot.
- That like us,
people here watched anime
at one point in their lives,
you know, and they're
very passionate about.
- What I hate about when
I have a take about anime,
and I'm sure you guys can relate to this,
is that no matter what, how
much I watch or what I say,
there's always some justification
as to why I'm wrong.
- I feel like it's not just anime.
It's just whenever you
watch something in general.
Like you and "Doctor Strange," I.
You've now angered-
- They're like,
What do you mean you haven't paid $15"
"for a Disney plus subscription"
"and watched nine hours
worth of sub content?"
"And I'm sorry that you don't
understand "Dr. Strange II""
"after watching only "Dr. Strange I.""
It's like, what's one
with you, Marvel fans?
Okay, I'm sure that'll be
in the next year's award.
- Yeah.
- But yeah,
this was one where I said
I watched nine episodes
and apparently that wasn't enough
to form an opinion, apparently.
- No.
- Of course it's not.
Of course it's not.
- So I stand by my take that "86" was bad.
- That's like judging one piece
and stopping at episode 100, you know?
Like how?
- That is valid, that is valid.
- After all the times you hear
it gets good at episode 800.
'Cause you didn't listen to them.
- Listen, listen, you
guys can enjoy the shows.
I just don't enjoy it.
That's it, get over it.
- All right.
Garnt, who won this one?
- Who won this one?
- All right.
- Please, ""JuJutsu Kaisen""
win. I just want it to win.
- And the winner.
- I don't want to win.
It better be bread.
It better be fucking bread.
- Of Hot take of the year goes to,
"90% of bread tastes the same."
(men applauding)
- You know what, I ain't mad.
- God damn it.
- I ain't mad.
- Yes, yes.
Anime takes are valid.
- Thank you.
- Are you saying that you think
that "JuJutsu Kaisen" is just okay, guys?
- Absolutely!
- It's just okay?
- It's just okay, Joey?
- Absolutely.
- Oh, come on.
- The most outrageous take of all.
- [Producer] Statistics.
- Wait, let's find out actually.
- All right, what is?
- 'Cause we have the statistics
of how close they were.
- What is the statistics?
- [Ashley] Do you wanna
know how many percent,
how much percentage of the
vote your hot take got?
- I want to guess that he got
like 60 to 70% of the vote.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] Well he got 66.9% of the votes.
Apparently a lot of people
thought his take was bad.
(men laughing)
- Wait, all of Europe came together
and I was like, "No, no."
- The entire German
population joined in to vote.
What are the, what are the rest?
- [Ashley] In second
place was you, Connor,
with "Food poisoning is not an illness."
- I'll take it.
- With 20.4% of the vote.
- [Connor] Oh wow, so barely
any for the other anime takes.
- [Garnt] And what were the other ones?
- [Ashley] ""JuJutsu Kaisen" was okay,"
came in third with 7.6% of the vote.
- [Connor] Oh.
- [Ashley] And Connor's second
take was the last with 5.1%.
- See, everyone agrees.
- So 95% of people agree with me.
- Everyone agrees with us.
- Yeah, just because one won
means that the others are right, right?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- That's not how the "Trash
Taste Awards" work, right?
- That's definitely how it works.
- I've been liberated.
I've been exonerated of cringe.
- Oh, thank God.
It wasn't a hot take, it was a good take.
- How do you feel about that, Garnt?
- I mean.
- Deserved?
- I wanted another one to win.
Yeah, that's probably
one of my worst takes
I've ever said on "Trash Taste."
- It is literally the take
that always gets quoted.
It's like whenever you
wanna discredit Garnt,
I'll be like, "Garnt
said this anime was bad."
"Yeah, but he said 90% of
all bread tastes the same."
- I'll be like, I'll
defend fucking pizza crust
or like not eating pizza
crust till the day I die.
I'm proud of that shit.
I'm just like, "Okay,
that's not my best moment."
You know?
That's like my dark,
that's like my dark past
I try to get rid of, man.
- Well deserved, well deserved.
- Oh, good start, good start.
- All right.
- What's the next category?
- [Joey] Next category is
the best out of context clip.
"I swear to God, this is
not what it looks like."
- Last year, what was it
"Bang bang bang," won?
- No it, oh yeah, yeah.
- It was "Bang bang bang."
- "Bang bang bang bang bang, shh."
Which is all my favorite clip.
- Which is still used to this day.
So it's gonna be hard to
see what can top this,
but what could top it?
- What could top this?
- What are the nominees?
- Garnt is sad.
This is a good one.
- You go through about 20
emotions in five seconds.
- I don't, what was like, what
was going through my head?
- [Connor] I don't know.
- I look at that and I listened back
to the conversation that this happened in.
I'm like, I do not know where I was going.
- It wasn't even a sad story.
- It wasn't even a sad moment.
It was just like, it was,
it's like the instant sad
face for like just a second,
and then like snap.
It was like the snap back
to reality moment, right?
- I still wanna know what
was going through your head.
- I wanna know as well.
- I would pay so much money
to figure out what was happening.
So much money.
- All right, and then
tits out for the boys.
And then before you know it,
It's like, there's like 15 Kayaks,
like 30 boys in this bay.
- Oh my God.
- Just all going, "Tits out for the boys!"
"Tits out for the boys!"
- Joey being misogynistic in the clip.
- I'm so happy this became a thing.
- Yeah, we definitely made it a thing
after the "Trash Taste."
- Charity stream.
- It did some good because we got.
- Yeah, wallets out for the boys.
- We got a lot of-
- We made a wholesome, guys.
- Yeah, we made wholesome, somehow.
- Hell yeah.
- [Connor] And then of course there's the.
- [Joey] This is from the stream.
- [Connor] Put a V-tuber
clip and we reacted.
- The most unfunny V-tuber clip, play it.
- We all reacted accordingly.
- What the fuck was that?
(men laughing)
- We were trying.
We were supposed to not laugh,
but apparently it wasn't hard.
- I almost laughed looking
at us reacting to it, right?
'Cause, like I wasn't
laughing at the clip.
I was just, I was like dead faced
and I saw us just like, I saw
this outta context clip live.
and I'm just like, "Yo, this
is fucking hilarious, man."
"This fucking hilarious, dog."
- I'd like to think.
- Oh my God.
- That this person submitted it as a joke,
but I don't think they did.
- No, I think they were
serious, unfortunately.
- I just like, this is
such, the best like,
you got the whole squad laughing,
just clip I've ever
seen in my life, right?
- And then next.
- And then we have,
touching my figures blindfolded.
- What the fuck?
- Yeah, it's huge.
There's a lot of bits
and bobs hanging off it.
- Oh.
- Smaller than shit, fuck.
God.
My God.
It just keeps going.
- I know, right?
- Holy shit.
- [Joey] I know exactly
where you're touching.
- Holy fucking shit.
- [Joey] I can't see,
but I know exactly what you're touching.
- Holy shit, this just keeps going.
- Is he on it?
- I guess 'cause we're describing
very sexual activities,
touching a figure.
- "I know exactly what you're feeling."
- It's the ferocity of Joey's kind.
- And then finally we have
Garnt, with gladly be racist.
I don't know what this is.
- Yeah, I don't know this one either.
- So, I guess let's have a look.
- Yeah.
- I would be, I would gladly be racist.
(men laughing)
- All right, well there we go.
- What was the context on that?
- When did you say that?
- I guess that's a good
outta context clip, aye?
- That's just, that's
so good outta context,
'cause I don't know the context.
When would I say that?
- I think it was-
- Why would I say that?
- Was it like towards kids?
- [Producer] No.
- I don't know what it was,
but just the poise you said it in.
It was like, "I would gladly be racist."
You're standing up for something
you're really believing.
- No, no, no.
Do I have like a split
personality and like,
the second Garnt is just like
really racist or something?
- [Ashley] I think you were saying
you would gladly be racist towards wasps.
- Oh, that was it.
- Oh, the wasps, that's right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- All right, well should we
found out who the winner is?
- Yeah.
- I wanna know.
I have no idea with this one.
- I really want the "Sakura Miko" to win.
- Yeah, I want the "Sakura Miko."
- I feel like I know
which one's gonna win.
If I had to, if I was a
betting man, Garnt is sad.
- Really?
- Right, right.
- Yeah, so true, too.
- Yeah, that's a really good one as well.
- And the winner is,
drum roll, please.
Garnt would gladly be racist.
- What?
I mean, to be fair, it
is amazing outta context.
- That ain't me, that ain't me.
That ain't my man.
- This you?
- That ain't my mans.
- Garnt would indeed gladly be racist.
- Oh my God.
- What was the percentage that it won by?
- [Ashley] This was really close.
- Okay.
- Oh yeah?
- [Ashley] Garnt would gladly be racist
won with 31.9% of the vote.
- Ooh.
- Okay.
- [Ashley] Second place is Garnt is sad,
with 31.1% of the vote.
- Oh.
- 1% difference.
Garnt is just the best out of context.
- The only one that can beat me, is me.
- He's an out of context
machine right here.
- He is.
He was two time winner.
- Yeah, right?
- Two time winner.
- Out of context winner.
- I ain't even trying, baby.
I ain't even trying.
- What where the other ones?
- [Ashley] Tits out for
the boys came in third
with 19.8% of the vote.
- I'll take that, I'll take that.
- [Connor] Let's go.
- [Ashley] Touching
anime figures blindfolded
came in fourth with 11.5.
- Oh, it came last.
- [Connor] I'm so sad
"Sakura Miko" came last.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- [Ashley] "Sakura Miko" came in fifth
with 4.3% of the vote.
- So sad, so sad.
- Damn.
- [Connor] But hey, can't win
'em all, can't win 'em all.
- [Ashley] Actually, yeah, no, yeah.
"Sakura Miko" came in last.
I don't why this to...
- That was a banger.
These are all banging clips.
- They're all banging clips.
- All right.
- But damn,
Garnt still holds the title.
The two time champion.
- Someone please take it from me.
I don't want this anymore,
I don't want this anymore.
- What is the next up?
What is the next category,
Joey? You have the card as well.
- Yes, the next category
is screen grab of the year.
- Ooh.
So I think we got a little bit
of crossover with this one.
'Cause I saw some of the nominations,
but there are a lot of,
I guess this is like out of
context, but just still images.
You know?
It's kinda like the same energy,
but you have even less context
'cause there's no clip
to go along with it.
- Yeah, true. All right, let's
see what the nominations are.
- Sad Garnt.
- Oh, we got sad Garnt again.
Wide eyed Garnt.
Angry Anki?
- I love this one, I love this one!
- But you need to see the
full picture for that one.
Me in a banana clown.
I don't remember doing that.
Connor takes his pants off.
That was used a lot of memes.
And then, oh, and I guess
it's the "Sakura Miko,"
us not laughing.
- Oh it's not "Sakura Miko."
It's just like, it's just like,
okay, so this is actually
really fucking hard,
'cause I don't know what my favorite is.
I think my favorite maybe
is just "Trash Taste" in a nutshell.
- [Connor] Yeah, do it.
- Just because like,
imagine it, okay?
You're a few episode
behind on "Trash Taste".
You don't know,
you forget that we're doing
like a 24 hour live stream.
You see that on your
timeline, and you're like,
"What the fuck is going
on with "Trash Taste?"
What is actually happening?
- It's that moment of like,
"Oh man, I haven't listened
to "Trash Taste" in so long.
I wonder what they're doing now?
And then you see that.
- Its like be over.
You've missed one
episode of "Trash Taste."
- Oh my God.
- I'd be wide-eyed Garnt.
I don't know how your eyes did that.
- I love wide eyed Garnt.
I don't even remember,
what did you, what was said
that made you react like that?
- I don't remember.
- I don't even remember.
- Man, you're talking about.
- It was probably like
you drinking Budweiser.
- We're talking about like
outta context Garnt here, man.
I don't fucking know that.
- [Producer] If I remember correctly,
someone said something, you were like.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I assume someone said something.
- That's what makes it
a good out of context.
- [Producer] Wasn't it the incest thing?
- Was it the incest thing?
- It might have been the incest thing.
- Why am I taking off my pants?
I don't remember why I did that.
- I don't know either.
- I don't know why.
- Although, your hand is like on the belt.
- I really got it off.
- I also just love how an image
from like five years ago
from a member that's not
even here is like nominated.
Why is that there?
It is a great image though, to be fair.
- Not "Trash Taste",
but I mean it's still on
the meme verse, I guess.
- Yeah.
- What would you say is your favorite,
"Trash Taste" in a nutshell?
- [Garnt] It's either
that or Angry Aki as well,
which is just, what was,
what was that photo?
What was the context?
What was the context of that photo?
- The context was,
so like the full images
on the screen right now.
But it's Aki looking pissed off
because she was sick, like car sick,
from when we went on a bus tour.
And I'm talking to my friend's
girlfriend at the time.
We're just having a conversation
and Aki's just looking really
pissed off looking at me
'cause she was really sick.
But out of context,
it just looks like she's pissed off
me talking to another female.
It's amazing.
- Especially like that meme image
of just like the girl looking pissed
and the guy looking at the other girl.
- The guy looking back, yeah.
Honestly.
- Yeah, but I really love
that image overall and,
but I, I gotta say "Trash
Taste" in a nutshell.
- "Trash Taste" in a nutshell.
- Like you could, there's
so much in this detail,
there's so much detail in this
image if you just look at it
that you just like discover something new.
- It's like a piece of art.
The longer you look at it,
the more impressive it gets.
- Yeah, 'cause like you look at it,
you're like, "Why is
Garnt in a clown costume?"
"Why is Joey in a banana suit?"
"Why is Connor wearing a monkey?"
- "Why did cum donate $6,969?"
- And then it's just like, what?
Current Sigma, cum?
What is going on?
There's so.
- I love how like there's just
so much shit on the table.
Like it's-
- A fucking mess.
- It's the most disgusting table.
- It's such a chaotic image that I just,
that's my favorite out context image.
- All right, would you like
to know who was the winner?
- We would, yeah, yeah.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- All right, so,
the winner of screen
grab of the year goes to,
(Joey makes drum roll noises)
Connor's pants off.
- Connor takes off his pants!
- To be fair, I think
that one's used a lot.
- That one's used in a lot of memes.
- That is used a lot, yeah.
- I also like it-
- It's the combination of that
and then me and Garnt doing this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, oh, no, no, no.
That is it, that is it.
- It's the combo.
It's the combo.
- It's missing the
second half of the combo.
- I just like how for two years in a row,
it's me wearing the same fucking shirt
in screen grab of the year.
I'm wearing the fucking Emiya shirt.
- So I'm like outta
context clip of the year,
then Connor comes along with
best screen grab of the year.
- Twice in a row.
- Twice in a row,
twice in a row.
- Oh my God.
- I do like this one.
I can't remember why though.
I just thought it, is
quite funny when people,
people always reply to
it with every tweet I do.
They always reply with this.
Every single one.
- 'Cause you could fit it with
so many different emotions.
It's like excitement, but
it's also like horniness,
it's like-
- It's just like the, "My
body is ready," kind of like.
- "All right, fine."
All right, what were
the percentages though?
- I'm honored, I'm honored, I'm honored.
Thank you, thank you, viewers.
- Yes.
- Yeah, what was the breakdown?
- [Ashley] So, Connor takes
off his pants one with 32.4%.
- That was quite close.
- That was close, yeah.
- [Ashley] Yeah, "Trash
Taste" in a nutshell
came in second with 20.4%.
- Ooh.
- Oh wow.
Nice, nice, nice.
- [Ashley] Sad Garnt
came in third with 19.3%.
- Of course.
- [Ashley] And then
Angry Aki came in fourth
with 12.8% of the vote.
- Nice.
- All right, nice.
- [Ashley] Then fifth
was Banana Clown Joey.
- I mean, that was just terrifying.
I don't blame people for not-
- Wow, wide Garnt was last?
- Yeah, I thought Wide eyed Garnt,
I thought banana Joey Aki, would be the,
oh, banana Joey Aki, banana
clown Joey would be the worst.
- [Ashley] Oh, sorry,
I'm reading it wrong.
Wide eyed Garnt did indeed come in fourth.
- Okay, I was about to fuckin'.
- [Ashley] With seven,
with 7.4% of the vote.
- Did you really have to like
make a deflection like that?
It's like Jebaited.
Actually, you came last.
- Jebaited, Jebaited.
- Fuck you.
- [Ashley] But not by far.
You came in last with
like 7.2% of the vote.
- [Joey] Okay, that's fine.
- Alrighty, what's the next category then?
Turn around and just saw my ass.
I shouldn't expect,
I knew it.
- What's the next category?
- I knew, I knew it was there, I just.
- Just thought, what's the next offer?
- Oh, foxy.
We got the most degenerative moment.
- Well, I think it's gonna
be one of you, right?
'Cause I'm very wholesome.
- I don't know, man.
You had some degenerate moments.
- Yeah, everyone has
some degenerate moments,
but let me just check that I have.
Yeah, it's most degenerate moment.
- All right, what are the nominees?
- What are the nominees?
- Okay.
Okay, okay.
- [Joey] We got Meilyne
talks about sweat and spit.
This is from our cooking special.
Play the clip.
- Have you ever licked sweat?
- I mean, not on purpose.
- Okay and how did it taste?
- Accidentally.
- I know what sweat is, Meilyne.
- I know, but like,
what kind of salty?
- I know it's salty.
Please don't tell me you
bucciaratied your husband.
- Not on purpose.
- A true Meilyne moment, that's for sure.
- This is like a normal moment
if you hang out with Meilyne enough.
She'll just say some things and like,
I'm glad that at least one of the moments
has finally been caught on camera.
- It's moments like these where I'm like,
I'm so glad I'm on Meilyne's good side.
Like, I don't wanna be on,
I don't know what the fuck she's gonna do
if I'm the bad side.
- You can literally see me processing.
Like "Where do I even start with this?"
You know when a friend says
something and you're like,
"What, uh, how?"
- I love there's like a one second pause
between after she says it
and me like mustering up an
answer, being like, "Uh."
- [Garnt] That's for recording.
- I remember you guys told me about it
and I was like, "Wait, what?"
"She what?"
"Why would she say that?"
- And the thing is, or actually, a bit of,
the full conversation had to be cut down.
- Yeah, she went on for
like 40 minutes about that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so what you see,
what you saw in the "Trash Taste,"
in the "Trash Taste Special"
was a cut down version
of the full conversation.
'Cause she was saying,
right, this was cut out.
She was saying that the sweat of the chef
has like a slight effect on the taste
of whatever we're cooking, right?
And that's why,
that's why we were talking
about sweat being a seasoning.
- [Connor] Actually vile.
- Because that got cut out.
So me, outta context, I'm just like,
I just go to Meilyne and like,
"Oh, so you want, so you
want us to go like that?"
Or something like that?
- yeah, just like,
just wipe that forehead, just bap!
- Yeah, so the context of behind that
was Meilyne was talking about
how sweat was like a seasoning
that changed the flavor of the food.
- That's so gross, dude.
- She's so gross.
- You didn't need to see
that part of conversation,
obviously, it was cut out for a reason.
- [Connor] Garnt bought an
ass holder for his phone.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Which is used over
there, actually, on the PC.
- Yeah, I don't. I mean, we
are still using it right now.
- We can't show it though.
- We can't show it.
- The patrons enjoyed that one though.
- The patrons very much enjoy that one.
- Play the clip.
- But the figure, its just an ass.
- [Connor] And we have to blur that.
- It's literally just an ass.
- Oh, this is like the,
this is like the way they get
sucked into a wall, right?
- That's the stuck in the wall.
- Stuck in the wall thing.
- But you only get half the
figure, so it's just the ass.
- I feel this is like a Wombo
Combo for the end Garnt video.
- I think two of these are Wombo Combo.
Just me and Joey just being
absolutely degenerates.
- I just love how you described it.
You're like, "It's just an ass!"
- Ass to ass, baby.
- And then next step we
have groping bumblebee.
- Oh my God, the title.
- Yes, oh my God.
- [Connor] Oh whoa, what the?
- [Garnt] Oh my God,
I thought we were still
showing the fucking.
- [Joey] Don't worry,
there's plenty to spare.
- What the, oh my God.
- Oh, that's my hand.
- Wait, wait.
And I coming?
- That's my hand.
- Oh, poor bumblebee.
- Garnt like full on grabs
the crotch at one point.
I remember that.
- Yeah, I think it's cut off in this clip,
but I remember like cupping it.
- Cups.
- I remember like cupping
it, and I was just like,
I remember thinking like,
"What's that?" "It's so smooth."
- What were you trying to
get, like a massive ball sack?
What were you doing?
- He was like,
"Female, definitely female."
- I don't know,
I just wanted to feel the entire thing
just so I could be 100% sure.
That's it, that's it,
that's the only reason.
- [Connor] And then finally we have
Garnt and Connor reveal
their lewd anime figures.
- [Joey] Play the clip.
- This is from one of my
favorite artists, Yum.
- All right, okay, I'll give it to you.
That's pretty fucking hot.
(people laughing)
- [Joey] Let's go!
- Is that removable?
- I don't know.
- Well guys.
- It looks removable.
- Degenerates, degenerate, degenerates.
I'm not the degenerate here.
I bought it.
They were the ones who inspected it with,
with such vigorous energy.
- You made a massive
mistake giving it to us.
'Cause, I remember you just inspect.
I just had to like appreciate
the detail, you know?
Like on the cooch, like
I'm just like, "God damn."
- Is that, I was like, "Is
that what that look like?"
It was awesome.
I loved it.
- I mean.
- I mean, geez.
- As much, as degenerate as
that was, it's gotta be Meilyne.
- It's gotta be the Meilyne one, right?
- Must be Meilyne.
- I'll be shocked if it's not.
- I'll be shocked, yeah.
I'll be disappointed if
it's not the Meilyne one.
- All right, let's find out.
- I hope so, so I can give her shit.
"How's it feel to be"
"the most degenerate person
in "Trash Taste", Meilyne?"
- Let's out who it is.
- All right.
Let's see who won?
- Yeah.
- It's you.
- Oh, it's me.
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- He's like yeah, sorry.
(men chattering)
- I was like "Guys, guys, guys, anyone?"
- All right.
- Let's find out.
- And the winner of the
most degenerate moment is,
Meilyne talks about spit and sweat.
- Yeah!
- Well deserved.
- Well done, Meilyne.
You have somehow in like,
even though you're on camera
for like a 10th of the time,
it's like not even a 10th,
like 100th of the time that we're on.
- She's been on three videos.
- You have somehow won
the most degenerate
moment in "Trash Taste."
- Wasn't even a competition.
- Wow.
- What a gamer.
- It wasn't even.
Was it close, Ashley?
Was it close?
- [Ashley] No, it wasn't
close. (men laughing)
- That's all we need to know.
That's all we need to know.
- Can I just know the percentage?
- [Ashley] What do you think it was?
- 70.
- 72.1.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- I knew it, I knew it.
- I don't even need to know the rest.
- Yeah.
- That's-
- Round of applause for Meilyne, everyone.
- Right.
- Meilyne's won her first
"Trash Taste" award.
- She's gonna come to
the office later today
and we're gonna tell her that.
- This episode is
sponsored by Express VPN.
- [Connor] Did you know huge
tech companies in America
pay next to nothing in taxes?
Meaning they barely give
anything back to society
that made them rich.
- How dare they?
- What?
- [Connor] They may
not do a lot of giving,
but they sure do a lot of taking.
- The audacity.
- [Connor] Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm talking about how these
tech companies enrich themselves
by taking your personal data.
They grab your web
history, email metadata,
and video searches to create
a detailed profile on you,
and then sell that off
to the highest bidder.
- What?
- Companies aren't just
selling products anymore.
They're selling you.
(Joey gasps)
- To protect your identity and
data from these tech giants,
I recommend using Express
VPN every time you go online.
- [Garnt] Express VPN
makes you anonymous online
by camouflaging your IP address
and replacing it with a different
secure IP of your choice.
Express VPN also encrypts all your data
so that it's protected from hackers
and anyone else who tries to spy on you.
And what I like the most by Express VPN
is how easy it is to use.
Just download the app on
your phone or computer tab.
One button and you're protected.
- Visit express vpn.com/trashtaste,
and get three months free
on a one year package.
That's express
vpn.com/trashtaste to learn more.
Back to the episode.
- All right, let's go onto
the next category then.
- Well, this is quite fitting,
'cause it's one that is close to my heart.
It's the saltiest moment.
- Dang.
- Yes.
- I had to take the
jacket off of this one.
'Cause it's gonna get hot.
- Staying fuckin' hot in here.
- No doubt I'm gonna be on here.
So let's see what the nominations are.
All right, we have Connor not
winning the cooking special.
- That's true.
- This is definitely salty.
- This is a salty moment that
has persisted to this day.
Connor to this day has not
let Meilyne go for that.
- [Connor] That's true, that's true.
Garnt learns that the Dead Sea is a lake.
- I'm pretty salty about that.
- I think we were all
salty about that one.
- I wasn't.
- That was like collective salt.
- I didn't vote for
that. So I didn't care.
- Connor not getting points
because of his own rules.
Oh, this is the "Feel
Good, Inc" one, right?
- Oh, this was the "Feel Good" one.
- I was very, very salty.
- You were very,
it was like, that was
one of the rare times
when it was just like I could,
it was like real, real salt.
- I dunno why I was so
salty for that part.
Like I don't, normally
I wouldn't give a shit,
but I just got so salty.
- I think it's because you,
you realized you fucked yourself over.
- Normally I wouldn't care, but this time,
for some reason, I cared so much about it.
- 'Cause like,
this exact moment was like energy
of just little brother
is just like, fuckin'-
- [Connor] Yeah, I was,
I was channeling that.
- It was like, "I told
you to get off the Xbox."
You're just like, "Fuck, fuck."
- "Fine, fine."
- The boys finding out they
gave Budweiser a 7.5/10.
- 7.5.
- Oh, God.
- That's not even a salty moment.
- Just shameful.
- That's just like,
a shameful moment.
- Shameful moment.
- That is a shameful moment.
- We were very salty about it.
- We, we were salty about.
- I love how none of these
are from normal episodes.
- Oh yeah.
- 'Cause we're not very salty normally.
- One's from a special and the other-
or , we're way salty on "After Dark."
- I feel like the amount of times
we argue about answers in "After Dark,"
I feel like you can,
I feel like four categories
just isn't enough sometimes.
You know?
- Yeah.
- I'm kind of shocked
that some of the figure
special stuff wasn't in here.
That was a very salty special.
- Oh true.
When like trying to decide,
like delegate points, right?
- Yeah, we got very salty in it.
- I believe that was like more,
I think we're gonna see it again
on like the best arguments.
- Oh God.
- Hm.
- 'Cause I think like,
how do you distinguish between
salty and arguments, right?
- [Joey] Sure, sure.
- I see the level of anger
with an argument being it.
- Yeah, that's true, that's true.
But I believe these, for saltiest moments,
I believe if they're, 'cause
none of these arguments, right?
- Yeah.
- So I think-
- They're just like, they're
just temper tantrums.
- Yeah, they're just, these
are just tantrums, okay?
- To be fair, Meilyne's
scoring of mine are gone.
So it was actually utter shit.
- I love my face in that fucking.
- Meilyne's already come,
has me already come on to defend herself?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, she did on "After Dark."
- She tried to.
- Yeah, she tried to, so I
can't remember what she said,
but she did come on to defend herself
on "Trash Taste After Dark."
I don't remember what episode that was.
- Which one do you think is gonna win?
- This is hard.
Holy shit.
- I genuinely don't know.
- Like this is one of
the hardest ones, right?
Because they are all really
really salty moments.
Like my God.
- I'm probably going to say,
just purely from the fact that it was
the most infamous moment in "Trash Taste,"
I would say the Budweiser one.
- Could be.
- 'Cause that one got memed to shit.
- Yeah, I think it's gonna
be either that one or.
- The cooking special, maybe?
- Oh, I dunno, I dunno.
- Fuck, fuck.
- I don't think it's gonna
be the dead sea though.
- Do we have clips to play with this?
- [Ashley] Yeah.
- Okay.
- So should we see how
salty we look in the clips?
- Yeah, let's check it out.
- That means I won!
Yes!
Let's go.
It's all right, Garnt,
you tied with Connor.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Absolute joke.
- Come here.
Come here, Connor, come here.
- No, I don't wanna see you.
- My fellow man, my fellow man.
- How much you pay Meilyne, huh?
How much did you pay
Meilyne, huh? Fuck off!
- Like,
physically, no.
On camera, it doesn't look
like Connor's that salty.
But Connor was very salty.
- Connor was actually salty, yes.
- On camera, like off camera,
he just like, that's like,
he got saltier as like the time went on.
It was like fine wine, but
just like with salt, you know.
It just aged more as time went on.
- [Joey] All right,
should we play the Garnt learns about
the Dead Sea's not a lake?
- Let's recess.
- It's a salt lake.
- Fuck.
- Oh.
- Wait, so what's-
- What?!
Sorry, sorry.
Let me just, I am losing
brain cells right now.
Where you would call a land
locked lake the Dead Sea!
- I think that's the only
time in "Trash Taste" history
where Garnt has clipped the audio.
Like that, "What" was like,
it was like, "Oh my God."
People listening on headphones.
- I think I was just so disgusted.
I was just like my,
like you know when you just realize,
like something has very gone wrong,
something has gone wrong with the system.
- You literally threw down the
whiteboard like, "What the?"
- I'm like, "The world is broken."
Like "What is the point anymore?"
- You learned that people often lie.
- Yeah, honestly.
- I discovered that today.
- All right, let's play
Connor not getting points
because of his own rules.
- I don't want the point.
I just don't want Garnt to get the point.
- I agree with Connor.
We both get the point
and Joey gets nothing.
- No.
- What's "Feel Good, Inc?"
- I got Gorillas, "Feel Good."
- What was that, that you
said to me literally like two,
three questions ago?
- That is not the same.
- So he gets-
- [Ashley] I'll give you
a point for Gorillas.
- You said that you
need, just get the song.
- I didn't think I had to put "Inc" in it.
- Just get the song exactly right.
- What the fuck?
- That's the title.
- You are the one who argued this, Connor.
You are literally the one who argued this.
This is like karma compilation.
- No.
- Oh!
Oh, this feels so good.
- I think that wasn't like
so much a salty moment
as much as it like persisted
for a few rounds after that.
- I was very salty, I was very salty.
- If we had an instant karma award,
then that way definitely win, for sure.
- If we did, yeah.
- That would absolutely win.
All right,
and then the boys find out
they gave Budweiser a 7.5.
- [Garnt] We wanna forget about this.
- I say it's the Czech one.
- Okay, I said it's to check one as well.
- I don't know the German beers,
so I'm just 50/50ing it, it tastes German.
- All right, ready?
- Okay.
- [All] Three, two, one.
- No!
- Ah!
No, no!
- How?
How does this taste good?
- That like, I remember like,
I dunno if that's salty because you can,
you can really feel the despair
in the third "no" that I
shouted there, I think.
- That was like an Oscar
award worthy "No," like.
That was like,
that was like, that's some
real shit right there.
- You know how they say no
is like unrealistic dialogue,
you know, that you shouldn't
include in your script?
That's obviously not true.
- That's some real shit right there.
- That was true despair right there.
If you're feeling true despair,
yes, you do shout out, "No."
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, now that I think
about it, it's probably,
it might have a chance
of winning, but like,
that was not so much salty
as that was just like-
- Shame.
- That was shame.
- Shame, shameful.
- And despair.
- All right, let's find out then, I guess.
- Yes.
- The jacket is off for this one.
- The winner is.
Connor not getting the points.
(men laughing)
- You know what, that's
worthy. That's pretty worthy.
- That is worthy, that is worthy.
- That's worthy.
- God damn it.
- What were the percentages for that?
- [Ashley] This was really close.
- Oh, okay.
- I'm not surprised.
This was one of,
this is probably the
hardest category so far.
- This is easily the hardest one.
- [Ashley] Connor, you won
with 31.6% of the vote.
- [Joey] Okay.
- [Ashley] And you came in second as well
with 31.1% of the vote.
- [Joey] Oh, 5.5%.
- For not winning the cooking special.
- I'll take that.
I'll take it, I'll take it.
Anyone who can be saltier than me, is me.
- And then which one was
better, Budweiser or other?
- [Ashley] Budweiser was
third with 30.9% of the vote.
- [Joey] Oh, wow.
- [Garnt] Wait, what did
the dead sea one get then?
- [Ashley] Dead sea came
in with 6.4% of the vote.
- Oh, wow.
- Damn.
That was like a three horse race then.
- I mean, that's like,
I thought the Dead Sea one
would get a little bit more,
'cause like that's a rare
sight where Garnt is salty.
You don't often see that.
- All right, wow.
That was very close.
- Next up.
- Next one is the most monkey award.
- Woo!
- Well, we're probably gonna expect
about six nominations from Connor.
- I've completely forgotten
the nominations of this.
- [Joey] Okay, first one
is, oh, it's one of two.
Okay, there's quite a few.
All right, so first one is
the boy's not running away
from a gas canister in the campfire.
- Yeah that was, okay.
- I ran away.
- That was the rare moment
where Connor was not the monkey.
That's when Connor kind of won.
- And then Connor was like the Neanderthal
to us monkeys at that point, you know?
Like he was like more evolved than us.
- "I have two IQ points higher than you."
Wait play, all right, play
the clip, play the clip.
- The torch was catching on fire,
the gas canisters right
next to it, I'm like,
"Uh-oh, uh-oh, fire plus can.
So I backed off.
I was running away,
these boys are just
sitting there watching,
watching, not helping, at all.
Just watching this guy holding
this gas canister on fire.
- I mean, yeah, it was pretty scary.
- And I think a lot of people like this,
'cause this is like one of our
most viewed TikToks, right?
- I think so, yeah.
- Or it initially was one
of our most viewed TikToks.
- By the way, follow us on TikTok.
- And YouTube shorts as
well, YouTube shorts.
Connor bought four Dio figures.
- Yeah, that was pretty monkey.
- Yeah, I did forget about that rule.
- Play the clip.
- Do Connor's four Dio figures
count as only one duplicate?
- So,
basically.
- Yeah?
- You know how?
(men laughing)
You know how we never said-
- I've never had a moment
where I'm just like,
"I'm about to hear bullshit right now."
- You know an argument is gonna be strong
when it starts with, "Um, uh."
- "So basically."
- I was trying to think
of some decent excuse,
but there was none.
I just completely forgot about that rule.
Until, you know.
- Until after it was over.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause what makes it even more monkey
is that you would've clearly
been ahead in the race.
'Cause you were clearly ahead in points,
and then you just kept
deducting points from yourself
because you bought so many Dio figures.
- So good, so funny.
All right,
next one is Garnt forgets
how to do long division.
Play the clip.
- [Ashley] Calculate
111,111 divided by 11.
- Shit.
- Uh.
- [Ashley] I'm hoping
Garnt will get this one
because I did teach him long division.
- I'll be honest, Ashley, I've forgotten.
- You know what?
- I have forgotten.
- The fuckin' beer's
starting to hit me, man.
I should have had more than a salad.
- I mean, in Garnt's defense,
apparently after that stream finished,
I was like watching back on the episode.
Apparently I just did it completely wrong,
but I still somehow
got the correct answer.
So.
- I mean,
I dunno why-
- How, how?
- I mean,
I dunno why it's Garnt forgets
how to do long division,
'cause me and Connor are in the same.
- Yeah, both of you.
- Me Connor are in the same boat here.
- Well, technically I forgot as well
'cause I didn't even do it right.
- Well because we, at least
you had a decent attempt.
I believe me and Conner just gave up,
even though we're the two engineers here.
Like we just couldn't figure it out.
- Use a calculator, innit.
- Just use a calculator, exactly.
- Next one.
- The boys get confused
by the Richter scale.
- Oh yeah.
- This is a very recent one.
- This is a recent one.
- Play the clip.
- Whoever designed the Richter
scale really fucked up.
It's not linear.
- Do you mean exponential?
- Expo, I think that's
the same thing, right?
- Well, I think
logarithmic is exponential.
- Oh it is logarithmic.
- Thank you, okay.
- But you were trying
to explain exponential.
- I smart, I smart.
- You said the right word,
but you were saying the wrong thing.
- The original point I was
trying to make was that the,
they put it in a scale
that is not comprehendible
by the normal human person,
which we are literally proving right now.
- Like decimals.
- I mean, compared to the others,
I would say this is on
the lower end, right?
- Yeah.
- Because, okay, we were arguing,
actually both me and
Connor were both right,
and we were both wrong.
In a sense here, 'cause I was like,
I said the Richter scale
was a logarithmic scale,
which it is.
I didn't realize that logarithms
are the opposite of
exponentials, which they are.
But those are like, those
are two different things.
- I remember I read up
on it after the episode
and I still didn't get it.
- The fact that we needed
actual mathematicians
to do a fuckin' three paragraph
long explanation of it,
just proves that, you know,
it might not be the most monkey moment.
Maybe because we are engineers,
they would expect higher, you know-
- It's not comprehendible by the brain.
- Thing is, when you got
an engineering degree,
but you don't use it for like six years,
you kinda, kinda forget.
- Yeah, you kinda forget.
- Look man, I can't do logarithms.
I can't do long divisions.
What makes you think I know
what a fucking logarithmic
scale is, you know?
- All right, we got a couple of other.
- Other nominees, huh?
- A couple of other nominees.
- Oh, oh do we really?
oh, it's one of two.
Oh wow.
- Okay, so this one is
the boys scream JoJo during countdown.
I love this clip.
I have stand.
- Oh!
- [All] JoJo, JoJo, JoJo, JoJo!
- That's good.
That's good, clear.
I like that one. That was
like, we didn't plan that.
We just kinda-
- Everyone thought that was scripted.
- That was like the rare moment
where we all shared the
brain, same brain cell.
Not just like me and Joey.
That was like we literally
devolved into monkeys.
I think that's like the most.
- That's probably the most monkey moment
right there, honestly.
- Just JoJo fans in a
nutshell, am I right?
- Garnt and Joey share the
same brain cell, as well.
- How have we only have one clip of this?
We got, like some of the biggest bangers
have had the girlfriend in the title.
- Oh God.
- Got "Domestic Girlfriend,"
got "Rent-A-Girlfriend."
"Girlfriend, Girlfriend."
- "Girlfriend, Girlfriend."
- There's so many other moments, though.
- I mean-
- But I guess this is
the feeling, in general.
- I feel like there's no one moment,
it's just every moment where we share the-
- That was one, like,
subtle moment where we
said the same thing.
- I have to ask that.
Why does Garnt get scared
by his own piss stream.
Why is that?
- Oh, I think that's from
the camping story, right?
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh.
- [Connor] He thinks things
rustling in the bushes.
- [Joey] Play the clip though.
- One of you guys say something
funny, start laughing.
I look over and I'm just like, you know,
"The boys are just being boys."
I look back over and I see
something, someone's breath.
Just like, going towards me.
- Like a white cloud.
- Yeah, like a white cloud.
I'm like, "Fuck."
"There's a monster hiding in that bush."
And then I soon realize
literally half a second in
that it's just my piss steaming.
- That's, that has to be top three, right?
- I mean.
- That has to be top three.
- That was like-
- That's very monkey.
- That was Neanderthal being
scared of like wild animals.
You know? I was like in alert mode.
- I think my favorite story
is just like imagining it,
like in context, right?
You just turn around you're just like, ah!
Oh, it's just my pee.
- 'Cause I was slightly
intoxicated at that point
and I was just, yeah.
What else is there to say?
I mean, I do still feel the JoJo moment
is the most monkey moment.
- I would be disappointed
if it wasn't the JoJo one.
- I don't think it will be.
- You don't think so?
- I don't think so.
- What do you think so?
What do you think?
- I dunno, actually.
There's a lot. I just
don't think it's that one.
- Yeah, there's a lot of good stuff here.
- All right, well let's find out then.
- All right.
- I have it right here.
So the winner for the most
monkey moment goes to,
(Joey making drum roll noises)
Garnt gets scared by his own piss.
- That is the most monkey.
- That's pretty fucking
monkey, to be fair.
- All right, all right, I'll take it.
- I did say it was top three.
- Congratulations, Garnt.
- Congrats, Garnt.
- For the monkey award for this year.
- Yeah, you got the monkey award.
- Give me that, give
me that, give me that.
- Here you are.
- I'll take it, I'll take it.
- I'll take that home with me.
- I'll take that one. I'll
take that one, all right.
- What were the percentages though?
- [Ashley] Garnt won that one with,
hold on, 27.2% of the vote.
- Okay.
- But there was more nominations here.
- Yeah, there was like seven nominations.
- What was top four?
- [Ashley] Top four.
Yours obviously was the first.
Second was the boys not running
away from a gas canister,
with 21.6%.
- Okay, yeah.
- [Ashley] Third was Garnt and
Joey sharing one brain cell,
with 19.6% of the vote.
- Okay.
- [Ashley] And in fourth place,
Connor with his four Dio figures at 13.6%.
- Wait, the JoJo one didn't make it?
- Aw.
- Sad, see.
- I'm sad, I'm sad, I'm sad.
- Sad.
- That just must mean like
it's a normal behavior, right?
- Yeah, JoJo fans look
at that and was like,
"Nothing new here."
- "What's monkey about that?
- This is not monkey.
This is very normal behavior.
- That's just normal behavior.
- That's just culture.
- All right, what's
the next category then?
- Best story.
- Oh.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- I mean we had a lot of great stories.
- So, what were the
nominations for this one?
- Let's find out.
Garnt was in a band.
- True, true.
- [Joey] Yeah, that is a
great story. Play the clip.
- I was actually in a band
myself. I don't, I dunno if I've-
- Were you?
- Yeah, I dunno if I've
ever talked about this.
- No, you've never talked it.
- We've never talked about this, no.
- Have I never mentioned this to you guys?
- Never mentioned it.
What did you even play?
- Yeah, what did you play?
- I played guitar.
- What?
- Are you serious?
- I'm serious.
- I didn't know this.
Did you stop play guitar?
- Why have we not started a band?
- I don't-
- No, I was offended because I was like,
"Why did you not tell me?"
We could have started a band years ago.
- You're like, "You were?"
- Yeah.
- "How dare you not tell me?"
- Dude, we could have brought
back 9 1/2 pounds years ago.
- Yeah, I know, I know.
- What The hell?
- Yeah, I mean like that was,
that was a fun story to tell
just because I completely forgot
that I hadn't told it before.
Because I think I did tell
it on like a previous,
or I mentioned it.
So I think I just assumed I had
already mentioned it before.
- Right.
- Right?
- I was offended.
What's the next one?
- [Garnt] Then there's
the boys went camping.
- [Joey] Posted a couple of
photos of us going camping.
And so many people
thought, they were like,
"Camping special?"
- Camping special!"
- "You're a camp special?"
- "Camping special!"
- No, it's not.
Who would have thought
that sometimes we just
hang out without cameras?
It's definitely like a full episode.
But I mean,
we had so many good stories
from that camp trip though.
- There wasn't like one story.
There's, just like that, that camp trip-
- [Connor] There's like five, at least.
- Was just like a gold mine of stories.
- Definitely.
- Yeah, and then there's
Connor's quarantine
hotel had armed guards.
- Wow, this one made it.
They took us all the
way from Haneda Airport,
which is like very south of Tokyo.
To the (speaking in foreign language).
We get to this hotel and I shit you not,
there is like 40 armed
guards at this hotel
for like 20 of us.
It was ridiculous.
- It's like literally squeak.
- I think I, one of my favorite
things about this story
isn't, it's the dichotomy
between our two experiences.
I think that what made the moment
and the story was just the absolute-
- Luxury.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Honestly.
- Like prison.
- [Garnt] And then, oh, this one.
- [Connor] Oh this one, what the fuck?
- The cock.
- The cock memes come from.
- [Joey] Oh.
- And then I look over and
in the corner of my eye,
I see a fat fucking cockroach.
I just ran in my room, just
like grabbed this mouse pad,
that was the closest thing,
and just ran back out.
- [Connor] No.
- I grab the tits out of things, right?
Wham it once, didn't work.
Wham it twice, didn't work.
So I'm just like fucking.
- Truly degenerate moment, Garnt.
- I love how you had to mention
that you were grabbing the tit though.
- I just, you know when you just remember
the most vivid details, you know?
You know what I mean?
- I remember that feeling in my hand,
and it felt great, baby.
- I cup in my hand.
I went to ham.
- [Garnt] And then we thought
our manager tried to scam us.
We couldn't find a clip for this,
but I remember the story
where I believe Joey told
the story where-
- Oh, this one.
- Yeah, Meilyne first emailed us.
- And I thought it was a scam email.
- You thought it was a scam
because we didn't know
that Book Walker / Kadakowa
tried to contact us.
- Yeah, they were like big company
trying to contact small (indistinct)?
No.
- It's like, yeah yeah,
where's the Nigerian prince?
Just tell me where the Nigerian
prince is, okay, right?
- Oh, we have a clip.
- Oh we do have a clip?
- Remember the first time
that Meilyne messaged me,
like to work with Book Walker.
- Thought it was a scam.
- I thought it was a scam.
- Honestly, honestly I thought
the same thing as well.
- First one, I fucking
deleted it immediately.
I was like, "Nah, that's a scam."
Get outta that.
And then Meilyne messaged me,
like emailed me again after
a week and she's like,
"I don't know if you read my last email,"
"but we're interested
in working with you,"
and I'm like.
- Oh, this is-
- "Did I delete that again?"
I fucking deleted that shit.
- [Connor] And the final nomination is.
- [Garnt] And the final, yeah.
Meilyne tried luring her cat with yogurt.
- [Joey] Ah, this edit is amazing.
- The moment you open
the yogurt cap, he knows.
It's like, and then he's like.
(Meilyne making scattering noise)
So I open the yogurt,
start swishing it around,
trying to make the yogurt noises,
and he finally came out.
(men laughing)
- That's such a chaotic clip.
- That would be a good like
out of context one, as well.
- Yeah, that would be a
great outta of context clip.
Just like Joey just like
meowing in the background
and Meilyne just like,
"So I tried to, I tried to
lure my cat out with yogurt."
- "I tapped the thing, and
then then the scurry come out."
- So Meilyne had an app
that was apparently,
they would translate
what your cat is saying,
and me and Jay were like, "Bullshit."
So we tried to meow into it
to see what it come with.
- I made it work once.
- Yeah, once.
- That was half of the clip.
The second half of the
clip was just Meilyne
literally trying to lure
her cat with yogurt.
- With yogurt.
- Who was stuck in a wall,
mind you.
- That's right.
- So bizarre.
It seems like a joke you're after.
It doesn't make sense.
- Like you know when you
do something in a dream
and it makes sense in the dream
and then you wake up and
you're like, "What the?"
"What kind of logic was that?"
That is literally that story.
- That's that.
That is a fever dream.
- Yeah, that's a fever dream, right?
- Oh man, any of these could win honestly,
but I would say,
I hope it's the Meilyne one.
- I generally don't know.
Maybe Garnt in the band.
'Cause that was-
- Garnt in the band, yeah.
- 'Cause that was such
a big deal when it came,
that story dropped.
- That caused a stir.
- When the Garnt story dropped.
- Yeah, I think that's like,
that one was probably the
most character development,
I guess is how you would call it.
- That's what they want.
They want the character development.
- They want the back story.
- In terms of like funniest,
I'm just like, Meilyne with a cat.
'Cause that was the
second time I'd heard it.
She told me that and I
was like pissing myself
the first time she told me.
And I was like, "Meilyne, you
gotta tell this on stream."
"This is like the best story ever."
- All right, let's find out then.
- All right.
- All right, Garnt.
Tell us who won.
- And the best story goes to,
Garnt was in a band.
- Yay, of course, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Not surprising, not surprising.
- I was in a band. Maybe I'll
pick up the guitar once again.
We have to start a band, man.
I'm saying.
- To prove it.
- We're gonna start a band.
- I'll help.
(people chattering)
- What are you gonna do?
- Like the triangle?
- Yeah, Garnt on guitar, me on vocals,
Connor on triangle, 10 1/2 pounds.
Let's do it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well I'm glad my band story,
I'm glad my experience as a
band was good for something.
- Well, what were the percentages?
- [Ashley] Garnt won that
one with 42.4% of the vote.
- Ooh.
- Oh, okay.
That's pretty significant.
- Nice margin, nice margin.
- [Ashley] His epic
battle with a cockroach
also came in second with 31%.
- [Connor] Man, Garnt.
- Garnt's just got stories, man.
What was third place?
- What's third place?
- [Ashley] Third place
was you guys going camping
with 9.8% of the vote.
- [Garnt] Okay, okay, okay, okay.
- [Connor] Wow.
- [Garnt] I mean, that was
just a story gold mine.
. All right, well I guess
what's the next category?
Oh, I think I have it.
I have it.
- Yeah, what is it, Connor?
- Biggest clown.
So I guess this is apt
that I'm doing this one.
- So yeah, so there's a lot
of clownery on "Trash Taste".
As you know, as you know.
It's most of "Trash Taste."
- Clown Taste.
- I mean, sometimes it
is just Clown Taste.
- Sometimes this is the circus.
- Yes, like most times actually.
- Yeah, most times.
- Sometimes.
Sometimes it's like, when
aren't we the circus?
So obviously there is going
to be our biggest clown
out of all of us.
- All right, let's check
out the nominations.
- Check out the nominations.
- [Joey] All right, so,
oh my God, these pictures.
- [Connor] So I guess
me, Garnt, Joey, Chris,
Meilyne and Ironmouse, I guess.
'Cause, from the charity stream.
- [Garnt] Yes.
- Oh my God, these images.
- Why is Chris nominated twice?
- [Joey] What is that
picture of you, Connor?
Fucking hell.
- [Connor] It's from my live stream.
- [Joey] It looks like mid exorcism.
- [Connor] I think it's cause
I was playing "Jump King."
- [Joey] Oh right.
- [Garnt] I love this shot of you, Joe,
from like this spicy ramen challenge.
- [Joey] Me going insane?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Luke did such a good job at that.
- Dude, that dude that was
literally a perfect shot
for like the, the anime
character going insane, man.
- Honestly, we could all get these.
So I have no fucking clue.
- I want Chris to win again.
- You won last time?
- Oh shit.
- Did you win last time?
- I did, yeah.
No, Chris won the other thing.
- That's just like selective memory.
It's like, "Chris won last time."
- Yeah, Chris, definitely Chris.
- Definitely Chris.
- I definitely didn't win.
Yeah, yeah.
- All right, let's see-
- That's like pure (indistinct).
- Let's see if you get
two years in a row then.
- All right.
I mean, there's not
much to say about this.
You know we're clowns.
You know we're all clowns.
- Oh, okay.
- Who do you?
- Do you guys think it's
like between me and someone?
Is that what you?
- It has to be be Chris.
- I think I have a good chance
of winning this, actually.
- Yeah, you were pretty clowny this year.
- Ah, true, true.
- You upped your clownery this year.
- I think I was respectable.
Like, not respectable,
but like on equal terms.
You know, I said pizza
crusts and all that,
but even that didn't bring
me to the clown category.
I just think like the bread.
- The bread one.
- The bread take was like so strong.
That was like the solo carry, you know.
- True, true.
- Well let me have a peep
first and I'll announce it.
- All right.
- [Garnt] Why are you peeping first?
- I just want a little peep
so I can do a dramatic reveal.
Fuck, it was me!
- Was it you again?
(people applauding)
Two years, baby!
- Two years in a row!
- Two years!
- Why?
Why do I do it again?
What the fuck?
- Two years in a row, baby.
I'll drink to that.
- I will drink to that.
- How?
Why are you voting for me?
I'm not the clown.
- Well let's-
- You know-
- Well what are the
percentages? Let's find out.
- Yeah, what are the percentages?
- [Ashley] Connor was the biggest clown
with 42.1% of the vote.
- [Joey] Who came second?
- [Ashley] Garnt was
the second biggest clown
with 33.1% of the vote.
- Seems like the majority is like you two.
Fucking hell.
Who was third, actually?
- Who was the-
- Slam it twice.
- [Ashley] Third was Chris.
- That was Chris, all right.
- I'll take being second.
You know what, I said the bread take.
I was literally wearing a clown costume
in the 24 hour live stream
and I still didn't win.
- Next 24 hour live
stream, he's gonna wear it.
- I feel like they're doing it
just to spite me at this point.
How dare you?
- Every nomination, like
for the saltiest moment,
every year should be Connor
winning the biggest clown.
'Cause he was very salty last year.
So salty in fact, that
he's forgotten about it.
He's just wiped it from his memory.
- I'm gonna-
- I thought Chris won.
- I'm gonna repress this one.
I'm gonna repress this again.
This is going in the
repression memory bank.
- All right, the next one
though, is the opposite.
It's the biggest Chad.
- It's the biggest Chad.
- Biggest Chad.
- Oh, is that the opposite?
- Is it the opposite?
I dunno.
- There are two personalities,
clown and Chad.
- Clown and Chad.
- Clown and Chad, yes.
- There is no in between.
All, what are the nominees?
- What are the nominees?
- [Joey] Oh, you got some
nice photos for this one.
- [Garnt] Oh, you got some nice photos.
- [Joey] Okay, but we also got
DemonDice Karen and Ashley.
Oh, and cum, cum.
- Yeah, I mean I've,
I put my vote for cum.
- I put my vote in for cum as well.
- What else do we have?
We have more as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Oh we have, oh, some more.
- [Connor] There it is, too.
- All right, we got Jan,
Kson, Mori Calliope,
Chris Broad, and Lake Mega Chad!
You know, thing that
doesn't exist anymore.
- I mean, if we're speaking
on like literal terms,
there's probably like a
clear winner here, right?
- Yeah, obviously it's-
- Literally, literally the biggest.
But yeah, I mean, I gotta
put in my vot in for cum.
I mean, he-
- I'm putting my vote in for cum.
- He, by himself.
I think we figured out he donated like-
- Over $10,000, yeah.
- Over $10,000.
- I think it was over 15,000.
- Wow.
- Over 15,000.
- He deserves it most.
- So without him, we would've like raised,
I think like 100 and-
- 80,000, it was total.
- 180,000 total.
- Yeah.
- So like he was 15,000
of that, which is like,
fucking insane.
- One man putting the
world on his shoulders.
- Yeah, yeah!
- Yeah, literally.
- One man putting the world on his back.
- [Connor] Another shout out to cum.
- And it is cum.
- We still don't know who you are, cum.
- Yes, yes.
- But let's see,
who the biggest Chad is of this year.
The biggest Chad of "Trash Taste" 2022 is,
cum.
- Yeah.
- Woo!
(people cheering)
Well deserved.
- Only on "Trash Taste" will you ever see
a fucking card that just says, "Cum."
- I love that there's
cum, lowercase as well?
- Yeah, lowercase cum.
There it is.
- Thank you, cum, thank you.
Everyone give their thanks to cum.
- Thank you, cum.
- We don't know who you are,
but you are indeed the biggest Chad.
- You are indeed the biggest Chad.
- Well deserved, well deserved.
- What was the percentage of cum votes?
- [Ashley] Cum was 39.4% of the votes.
- 39%!
- That's quite a lot for-
- Holy shit.
- For seven plus, no, eight nominees.
- [Ashley] That's a lot of cum.
- Yes, that's a lot.
- That's a lot of cum.
- That's a lot of cum lovers.
- I think everyone can agree
that cum was the biggest Chad this year.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Of course, easily.
- I feel like if you didn't vote for cum,
you probably didn't know the
context of why cum was there.
- Yeah, you missed out
on the charity stream.
- We, no one knows what cum is,
but we're grateful that we have it.
- No one knows who cum is.
- No one knows who it is, what it is.
- Yes.
But he definitely is not
only the current sigma,
but the-
- The forever sigma.
- Forever sigma.
- The Chad of 2020.
- Chad of 2020.
Of 2022.
- Two, 22.
- 2022.
- Yeah, 2022.
The same shit.
It's never, we haven't even been.
- All right, what's the next one?
- Garnt.
- So the next category.
Who is like, what was like the other?
- It's irrelevant.
- Okay, okay.
Cum is the biggest Chad,
that's all you need to know.
Oy oy oy, it's your
boy, Josh the Manga Lad,
here to let you know that this episode
is sponsored by Honey,
the easy way to shop online
with your iPhone or computer.
As a certified Zoomer,
you know that all the
shopping I do is online.
But sometimes I wanna save that money.
I wanna get those promo codes,
but they don't come as
easily as I thought.
So what do you do?
You use Honey instead.
Because thanks to Honey,
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past.
Honey's the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones
it finds to your card.
Look, I'm gonna break it
down on how it works, okay?
Just listen to this.
Imagine you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites.
When you check out, the
Honey button appears
and all you have to do
is click "Apply coupons,"
wait a few seconds as Honey
searches for the coupons
it can find it for that site,
and if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch those prices drop.
I love shopping for a lot of vinyls
and records for my record player,
and I actually saved
around $20 on an album
I really, really wanted.
That is an absolute
steal, thanks to Honey.
I'd never recommend something I don't use.
So get Honey by going to
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Link's in the description.
Back to the episode.
- Best nickname.
So like.
- Okay.
- We're not, wait,
are we pulling nicknames
though from last year?
- Are we?
- No, we're not, we're not.
- These are the ones that
were made this year, right?
- Did you win last year?
- I, oh I mean Garnt,
well me naming Garnt,
- Steve Hand Jobs.
- Oh, I thought it was Karen.
- No no no, it was Steve
Hand Jobs that won last year.
- Again, selective memory.
- Connor's just got selective memory.
- Yeah, he's-
- What the fuck?
- I think we realized
who Connor's voted for
by his selective memory.
- I don't even remember if
that was a nominee or not.
- It was a nominee.
- Was it?
- Yeah, I voted, no.
- Are you sure?
- I didn't vote.
- I put 20 votes in it.
- I thought it would be insider trading,
so I didn't vote, you know?
- [Garnt] Yeah, so I mean-
- Yeah, Steve Hand Jobs won last year.
I mean, so we get a lot of
memes and a lot of nicknames
that come out of our
"Trash Taste" recordings.
I thought, I actually thought this year
that we didn't have
any nickname nicknames.
I was like, "Have we, do we have enough?"
- [Connor] We had a lot.
- "To get nominations?"
- Did we?
- And then I saw the nominations.
I'm like, "Oh, there's
even more than last year."
- We had a lot, we had a lot.
- We had a lot, so.
- Okay, let's see them then.
Let's, what are the nominations?
Oh, okay.
- Dr. Ligma.
- [Joey] Okay, we had Dr. Ligma.
- [Connor] Yeah, what a great name.
- The legendary Dr. Ligma.
- Legendary.
- [Joey] We had Little Baby Man.
- [Garnt] Little Baby.
- [Joey] I mean, I think
that's supposed to be Garnt,
but you know, who knows?
We had Josh The Manga Lad.
- Josh the Lad.
I fucking love that.
- Where did that come from again?
- Oh, for one, I don't watch
anime anymore, and then two,
one guy at the convention
called me Josh, unironically.
- So it was Josh The Manga Lad.
- Josh The Manga Lad now.
And then obviously Mr. Affable.
- [Connor] Mr. Affable,
of course, of course.
- [Joey] Next one.
Oh, us calling Meilyne, Mum.
- I mean, that's not a nickname.
She is, she is our mother.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] And then God.
- God.
- Oh, that's your nickname.
- Yeah, that was someone
mishearing my nickname.
And then.
- [Joey] And then Dee Z Nuts.
- Dee Z Nuts.
- From the TLPG stream.
- Yes, yes.
- Wow, solid names.
I don't know who's gonna win.
That's all, could be, I don't know.
- What was the first one again?
- Go back to the first page.
- [Connor] Dr. Ligma.
- [Joey] Dr. Ligma.
Oh man.
- I love Dr.
I really hope Little Baby Man doesn't win.
- I think I-
- Really.
- If I was a betting man,
I'd pretty bet Mr. Affable.
- I would say Mr. Affable.
- 'Cause that one got a lot of mileage.
- Yeah, that was-
- Yeah.
- That was like,
when Chris came on and
he just said affable.
Now he's just known as
like the affable guy.
- That was the episode
where everyone in the world
learnt the word affable.
- Yeah!
- Before that, it was not a word.
- And then like now I can't stop using it.
- All right.
- Yeah, all right, let's find out then.
- Let's find out who won, men.
- And the best nickname of 2022 is,
Mr. Affable.
- Yeah!
Of course.
- Aye.
- Good on you, Chris.
You are Mr. Affable.
- You know the downside of this,
it means that Chris has a chance
to win more than one award this year now.
- Oh.
- Oh fuck.
- 'Cause he only won one last year.
- Yeah, true, true.
- He's gonna be so made up, fuck.
- What were the percentages there?
Well, top three, just name top three.
- [Ashley] Top three.
Top was Mr. Affable
with 32.7% of the vote.
Second was Little Baby Man
with 20.9% of the vote.
- Know what, actually I'd
say that. Thank you, Chris.
Thank you.
Thank you for, thank you for winning.
- [Ashley] And Josh The
Manga Lad came in third.
- Yes!
- 16.3%.
- God damn it.
- That's not what I wanted to hear, baby.
- All right, fine.
All right, what's the next one, Connor?
- Oh, it's me, right.
That's right.
- Yeah, it's you.
- Next up is, oh my favorite.
Best Complaining About America Award.
- Oh, we had plenty of these.
- Oh, okay.
- Plenty of these.
- God knows.
- Like how do we narrow these down?
- Where do we, how do we narrow it down?
- How do we begin?
- Let's have a look at the
nominations then, boys. Shall we?
- [Joey] Yeah.
All right, so first one is
explaining why Budweiser is bad.
- If there is an instant
karma compilation,
this would also be on it.
- All right, play the clip.
- The thing is I never tried
a Budweiser up until now
because all I've heard is
that it tastes like shit.
So that's why I never tried it.
But now, I kinda like it.
- [Connor] Sizes in Japan
versus sizes in the US.
I'm thinking that's
talking about coffee sizes.
- Yes.
- And food sizes.
- [Joey] Oh, right, right.
I see.
- I guess we don't need
to watch that clip, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's fine.
- I mean, I don't think we
need to watch all these clips
because they're gonna be very long clips.
- True, true.
- There's a lot of, so
we can explain them,
because I remember most of these.
There's very few things I do
remember on "Trash Taste,"
but complaining about America
is definitely one of them.
So yeah, explaining why Budweiser is bad.
I'm not sure if that was a
complaining about America moment
as much as it was-
- Budweiser is America.
- Yeah.
- It's an amalgam.
- It's an amalgamation of America.
- No no no, as much as you-
- Maybe Mexico.
- As much as we're just complaining
about American beer, period.
- Yeah.
- And then we,
we definitely shot ourselves in the foot.
And then, in our own faces afterwards.
Sizes in Japan versus sizes in the USA.
- Coffee and stuff like that.
Everything.
- Everything, everything.
- In America just being too big sometimes.
- Everything is just too big.
- [Connor] Also yeah, America's
stupid way of writing dates.
- Okay.
- Which it is.
Come on, you gotta admit it.
- I mean, this isn't even a
"Trash Taste" complaining.
It's just worldwide at this point.
- This is the world complaining.
- [Connor] And then of course
the Chef Mac insults New York
on the cooking special
in like record speed.
- I do like this one.
- I love this one.
- Because it was just
such a unplanned moment,
where we just had,
we were just trying to
be wholesome, you know?
We were trying to be comforting.
We had a guest on.
Just wanted to have a nice conversation.
Immediately complains about America.
- Like it wasn't even scripted,
that's the best part.
- No, no, no.
I was just gonna ask like,
"Oh, so how did you get your position?"
Or "What's your experience?"
And he just like, "Yeah, so uh, fuck you-"
- "Hate New York, it's
shit." (men laughing)
And then one time we had Meilyne on
and we needed some backup,
so we asked Meilyne
what she thinks about us
talking shit about America.
Which was us complaining about
us complaining about America.
And then of course we had the Americans
that microwave their water.
- Yeah, I will never forgive that.
I will never forgive that.
- That's unforgivable.
- That is unforgivable.
- That is a war crime.
- That is Geneva Convention
defying right there.
- And it's funny, 'cause the only one,
one of the biggest ones,
aside from this one.
One of the biggest ones I've
seen Americans still defend
is the microwave their water.
- That's just shocking.
- How could you defend that?
How?
- You know that clip's just like,
"I will never forgive the Japanese."
That's like-
- "I will never forgive the Americans."
- I just don't get it.
It just doesn't make sense to me.
- Just get a kettle.
- For this one though, I do
hope the Chef Mac one wins.
- I want the American
microwave one to win.
- Either of those could honestly win, but.
- It's between those two.
Just, I love the Chef Mac one
just for how unplanned it was.
And just like the fastest-
- How fast it was-
- The fastest bonding
experience to be like,
"Oh, you're one of us."
"Okay, okay."
You'll get a, you'll fit right in.
You'll fit right in.
- Definitely, all right.
- Well the winner is, gentlemen.
- Yes?
Let us know.
- Believe it or not, it's,
Americans microwaving their water.
- Oh shit.
- Oh!
(people applauding)
- Well deserved.
- Valid, valid.
- You know what?
I feel like the rest of the
world united in voting for that.
- W plus I ask plus I cared.
- Yeah, exactly right?
- What was the percentage that it won by?
- [Ashley] That one won
with 37.3% of the vote.
- Oh.
- Oh, nice.
- Okay.
- That's pretty big.
- [Connor] What came second?
- [Ashley] Second was you guys explaining
why Budweiser's bad,
with 18.8% of the vote?
- Fair enough.
- Fair, fair, fair.
- [Ashley] And Americans
writing that dates wrong
came in third with 18.5% of the vote.
- [Joey] Oh, that's surprising.
- [Garnt] I think it was just like-
- I'm so good at predicting these.
- Yeah, I think it's just
like the world uniting
about what they can, like
it's everything every person,
but Americans and like
coming together to be like,
what do we actually agree on?
- What's the most common complaint?
- Yeah, what's the most common complaint?
- All right, Joey,
what's the next category?
- The next one.
Oh, this one's gonna be a hot contender.
Best meme.
- Ooh.
- We had a lot of great
memes that the subreddit
and Twitter have created.
- Fantastic memes, fantastic memes.
- Honestly, any of these could win,
but let's see what the nominations are.
So for starters we have the dark timeline.
- Yes.
- Which I'm a little behind on,
'cause I think this kind
of came onto the subreddit
when I deleted Reddit off my phone.
- Yeah, this is, this
has come pretty recently.
And we haven't talked about it, I guess.
But it's still pretty timely
because it would've
been two weeks, I guess,
since the dark timeline started.
What the fuck?
- Yeah.
- I like-
- All I know is that it
makes fate look normal.
- I'm kind of waiting for it to finish.
- Yeah, let's all,
let's go through all the
categories first before-
- And Garnt sad, of course.
- Garnt sad.
Of course, of course.
- [Joey] Joey and Garnt synced, of course.
- [Garnt] Yes, of course.
- [Joey] Ironmouse is Chris, of course.
- [Garnt] I love that meme.
- [Joey] And then evil "Trash Taste."
- Evil "Trash Taste."
So I think the biggest difference
between this year's memes
and last year's memes
is that like our Reddit has
a hive mind of its own now.
There are two memes here
that we did not create.
- [Joey] No.
- Or we had zero hand in, okay?
Ironmouse is Chris.
How did that start?
- I don't know.
It was like two characters
that seemingly had nothing
to do with one another,
known in "Trash Taste" lore,
and then someone was like,
"What if they're the same person?"
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Which is great.
There was like such good fan art out of it
and everything like that.
Like the, I think one of
my favorites is the one
where Ironmouse is
parodying a mock of Chris.
Such good fan art.
- I think my favorite thing
about the Ironmouse is Chris meme
is that none of us are in it.
Like it literally has nothing
to do with "Trash Taste,"
and yet it's a "Trash Taste" meme.
- It just shows that
the "Trash Taste" lore
has gone, has expanded so much,
that it's like gone beyond "Trash Taste."
- [Joey] It doesn't even need us.
- Yeah, it doesn't even need us anymore.
- It's good though,
'cause then Chris went on
Ironmouse's talk show as well.
That never would've happened.
- Yeah, that was like the full circle.
And then the timeline, which
I believe is still ongoing,
right to this day.
- I think, I would bet my entire net worth
that the dark timeline is gonna win
just 'cause of the recency.
- Of course.
- And the subreddit loves it.
They all love it.
- But like, it's not
just like the recency,
because recency bias is also a thing.
- It's definitely recency.
- But it's take like,
I am fucking impressed
by the amount of effort
that has gone into this.
What, this is not a meme anymore.
This has gone beyond a meme.
It's, it is-
- Like, they're literally pulling,
they're literally pulling like a Tagashi
and like fucking graphing everything out
and being like,
"Okay, so this happens
while this was happening."
"And then this happens next."
- Yeah, it's just like "Fate"
fans and "Kingdom Heart" fans
think no one can like
defeat them until like,
they look like the dark
timeline and I'm like,
"Okay, I bow to my Lord."
Like I looked at like the timeline,
I'm like, "Fucking hell."
"How'd you make sense of this?"
- There's YouTube explainer
videos on the dark timeline.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, there's a few.
- Oh my God.
- And like-
- And some of them don't
even explain it very well.
They're like, "I don't
really get it, but."
- And the thing that
blows my mind the most
is that we have had zero
involvement into it.
We did not create it.
We did not even say
something that would like,
could like-
- Fuel it.
- That fueled it, you know what I mean?
It is like our subreddit
completely just having
a mind of its own.
Like it's, our subreddit is
self-sustaining at this point.
- [Joey] Honestly.
- These two memes prove it.
- Yeah, definitely.
All right, well let's find out then.
- Yeah.
- Who got the best meme?
- How much at the dark timeline win by?
- Yeah, let's find out, I guess.
So the winner for the best
meme of the year goes to,
the dark timeline.
- Yeah, not even surprised.
- Congrats, congrats to you guys.
- Congratulations, Reddit.
Your fan fiction made it.
- Oh my God, it's a fan fic!
- I'm not joking, it's
literally a fan fiction.
I'm not even joking.
- Why you gotta do 'em like that, Joey.
Why you gotta do 'em like that?
- It is, because-
- It's so much more than that, Joey!
It's a cohesive universe.
- I didn't sacrifice the past!
For you to call it a
fucking fan fiction, Joey!
- I didn't die in an earthquake
for you to call it a fan fiction.
- You don't know what I sacrificed, Joey.
- It doesn't even make sense.
- [Joey] I'm looking at this
and I'm like, first of all,
what the fuck is that
face on the left there?
- [Connor] Oh that.
That's from one of my live streams.
- It's terrifying.
- I gotta shout out the people
who actually made this fuckin' image.
I know how difficult and
how time consuming it is
to make an image like this.
It is-
- [Joey] It's sponsored by the BBC?
- [Connor] That's the initial timeline.
- [Joey] Oh, it's the initial timeline.
- Yeah, this is like, I mean,
this is like a really high effort meme.
You know, this is, yeah.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, this is a
extremely high effort meme.
And keep it coming.
Love the high effort memes.
- Honestly, yeah.
- I wanna see how it concludes.
- What percentage did it win
by, is the real question.
- [Ashley] Well, the dark
timeline came in first
with 35.1% of the vote.
- Oh, wow.
- That's not as much as I
thought it was gonna be.
- [Ashley] Second place Ironmouse is Chris
with 23.7 of the vote.
- Expected.
- Of course, of course.
- Literally the two memes that
have nothing to do with us.
- The dark timeline is all about us.
- No, but I mean like we did.
- We didn't, yeah.
- We didn't create.
- Yeah, we didn't do it.
- We didn't create it.
- This is like the Reddit, like
giving themselves the medal.
To be like, "Guys, we
did a great job, go on."
- Yeah, they literally
gave themselves an award.
- Every Redditor's standing up and like,
"We did it, Reddit, we did it."
"We did it, Reddit."
- Rejoice Reddit,
you won an award.
- My God.
Congratulations Reddit.
All right.
- Next up, Garnt.
- What's the next one, Garnt?
- The next category is,
"They actually talked about anime" award.
- [Joey] All right, so
this is the new one.
- So if you're a new
viewer of "Trash Taste",
you may not know this, but we
once were an anime podcast.
- No we weren't. No we, we
were never an anime podcast.
- We said we were.
- In literal episode two,
we didn't talk about anime.
- We once said that we
were an anime podcast,
and I don't know the exact
moment when we were just like.
- No, we started with the intention
of being an anime podcast,
and then by halfway through-
- No, no, no.
We didn't,
we started with the
intention of tricking people
into thinking we're an anime podcast.
- Like "Yeah guys, we're
definitely an anime podcast.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then-
- Definitely.
- It took way less time than
I thought it would to be like,
"No, we're not an anime podcast."
- One episode.
It took one episode.
- Literally episode two
we don't talk about anime.
- We did also talk about anime.
We are a podcast that-
- A decent amount.
- Yeah.
- I'd say a decent amount.
- At least I'd like to think.
- I'd like to think.
- Every now and then we spoke about it.
- Yeah.
- We gotta represent our original IP.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Let's see, all right.
So Connor watched all of "Mushoku Tensei."
Which I think was a
surprise to a lot of people.
- I'm still proud of him.
- It was, it was, it was.
- I'm still proud, yeah.
- They were very surprised.
- [Joey] To be fair.
Joey thought "JuJutsu Kaisen" was okay.
- Here we go again.
- And here we go again.
The boys talk about
"Berserk" for 30 minutes.
Oh this was when Miura sensei passed away.
- This is a shame,
'cause at this point I
hadn't read "Berserk."
- Yeah.
- It was,
and during the Manga episode,
we actually talked about it.
- It was-
- But that also, I think,
could have been referring
to the Manga episode.
- Yes.
- Oh, could be.
- [Garnt] I hope this one-
- I believe it was initially
supposed to be about the Manga episode.
- Yeah.
- I think so.
- Was this the one where we
had that unfortunate timing?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so like as much
as I like "Berserk"
and I'm glad we talked about
"Berserk" for 30 minutes.
- I think this is actually
referring to the Manga episode.
- Okay, okay, okay. We did
have this point as well.
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We've talked about,
we've touched on "Berserk"
a couple of times.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was amazing.
And then Connor and Garnt try
to get Joey to watch "Arcane."
"Arcane's" not an anime.
- It is, it is, it is.
It's an anime.
- It's a cartoon.
Come on, let's be real, guys.
And then-
- Copium Joey, right now.
- [Joey] And then the boys
talk about not watching anime.
How is that?
Wait, hold on a second.
How is that in this award?
Okay.
- Can I see this clip?
- Yeah, can I see this clip?
- Was this the last one?
- You guys voted for these
nominations, by the way?
- Really says a lot about anime
when all it takes is for
me to read a synopsis,
and I could probably tell
you with 90% accuracy
what the first three
episodes of that anime
is gonna be about, in a detailed way.
Yeah.
- Yeah,
we were such an anime podcast
that we had a fuckin'
20 minute conversation
about not talking about anime anymore.
I remember this conversation, holy fuck.
- I still stand by that point
I made though, definitely.
Ah, well fuck.
I mean, I purely just from the fact
that it was nominated in the other ones,
I would probably have to say
me thinking "JoJutsu
Kaisen" was okay, right?
- I want that one to win.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- I just want it to get
some representation.
- I want that to get the dub.
It didn't get the dub last time.
- I want it so nobody forgets
that Joey thinks "JuJutsu Kaisen" is okay.
- I will keep reminding
everyone, every day.
All right, let's find out, I guess.
- All right.
That's not me.
- No, it is absolutely you.
- Garnt, you picked it up.
- Oh, right, right, right,
right, right, right.
I'm on a-
- It's the dark timeline.
He's got dementia.
- This man's two champagnes deep.
- What timeline am I in?
And the winner is.
- Who's the winner?
- Garnt and Connor try to
get Joey to watch "Arcane."
- Oh wow.
Okay.
That's surprising.
- As you should have watched it by now.
- Yeah, I definitely will.
- We tried you to get, watch it.
How many episodes ago was that, like 30?
Fucking watch it.
- I think it said episode 77.
So that's 30 ep, like,
it is now-
- Half a year ago
we tried to get you to watch.
- About 20 episodes ago.
- It is now zero days since
"Arcane" was mentioned.
- Yeah, I know, right?
Christ almighty.
- Watch it.
Watch "Arcane," it's amazing.
When season two comes out,
it'll happen all over again.
- What percentage did it win by?
- [Ashley] That one won
with 24.9% of the vote.
- [Garnt] Ooh, must be close then.
- [Joey] That's really close actually.
- [Connor] What came second?
- [Ashley] In second place
with 23.5% of the vote,
Connor watched all of "Mushoku Tensei."
- [Connor] See, I would've
voted for that one.
I thought that would've been.
- That was surprising.
- Really shocking, yeah.
I remember when you said that-
- Because that's actually when
we would talk about anime.
- What, what?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like,
"Connor took my recommendation
about an Isekai?"
What?
- Never happens.
- Yeah.
Oh wow, all right.
- I like the fact that it's the,
they actually talked about anime awards
and the "Arcane," "Arcane" won.
- It's an anime, it's an anime.
- Yeah, definitely an anime, guys.
- I just like saying
that to fuck with people.
Who care about whether
something is an anime or not.
- Next up.
- Next one is, ooh.
- It's Connor, isn't it?
- It's me.
- Oh it's you?
Okay, sorry.
- Everyone's in the wrong timeline now.
- Yeah, everyone, yeah.
Everyone's not figuring it out.
- [Connor] The best tangent ward.
- [Joey] So all of "Trash
Taste," essentially.
- [Connor] The entirety
of "Trash Taste" podcast.
- [Joey] All right, lets see it.
- If derailing a conversation
was an Olympic sport,
we'd be the world champion.
- We'd definitely be the world champions.
- We would, we would.
- Let see the nominations.
- What are the nominations?
- [Connor] I'm gonna
do it, I'm gonna do it.
- [Joey] So three things you would take
to a deserted island.
Okay.
- Is that a tangent?
- I guess it's kind of.
- Yeah, kinda was.
- Yeah, because the question
was suddenly like thrown
out of nowhere, right?
- I threw it out there just randomly.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- [Joey] And then talking about dreams.
- Talking about, are we
watching the clips with these?
- You can.
- All right, I would like to.
'Cause I want,
I would like to see our reaction
to some of the tangents,
if there are reactions to the tangents.
- Yeah, play the first one first.
- Can I take a boat?
Like a really nice yacht?
- I'll just take my $6 million mansion.
- No one said the scale
of items I can bring.
Why can't I bring a boat?
- Well then I'll bring a
jet and get the fuck out.
- Okay, so like,
I think some of these might
have more immediate tangents.
We'll see, we'll see.
- Well, because some of these
inspired entire episodes, right?
Like the talking about dreams one.
I think it was just one tangent.
- What led, what to that?
- I don't know.
Oh, I think it was about you
talking about Sydney having fever dreams.
- Yeah, okay.
- And then we went-
- Oh yes.
- And then the rest of the
episode was just about dreams.
- That was a tangent that
defined an episode, you know?
- I don't even remember what the fuck
we were talking about before that.
- That was actually one of my
favorite episodes to record,
because I was just,
it was just such a weird conversation
that I've never had before.
- [Joey] And then Connor
thinks deer are the scariest.
- Valid.
- Valid, valid.
- [Joey] Oh, I love this one.
Turkish taxi drivers are the mafia.
Can you play this clip, actually?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah,
I wanna play this clip.
- Army of taxi drivers
ready to beat you up.
Like literally.
- Why taxi drivers?
- Bro, 'cause they're like
the mafia of Turkey, bro.
- What?
- Dude, in Turkey they say,
"Don't fuck with bus
drivers or taxi drivers."
Fuck with one of them, you call
up the entire neighborhood.
- What?
- Dude, like-
- That single handling made
me not wanna go to Turkey.
- Yeah, right?
- That sounds terrifying.
- What are you gonna do,
piss off taxi drivers?
- No, I don't know.
I don't know where their fuse is, right?
- [Connor] Next page.
- That was such a weird tangent to go on.
- [Joey] And then the boys
want to eat extinct tortoises.
- [Garnt] Oh, the boys want
to eat extinct tortoises!
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, I remember this one.
- [Connor] It's great, this is a good one.
- [Joey] And then Jan talks
about the Itachi sacrifice.
- I wanna watch, I wanna watch this one.
I wanna watch this one
'cause I remember having visual
shock to this one, I think.
- So basically, you know,
Itachi sacrificed his whole life being
for the greater good that he believed in.
A shoe he had to fill in
at a age that, you know,
even he had no understanding
or conscious about.
- Okay?
- Stop laughing, bitch.
(men laughing)
- I think Connor sums it up there
because I remember he was having,
what was he talking about before then?
- I don't know.
It was some nonsense.
- He was talking about how,
like a host he respected
or something, right?
- Yeah, and then he was suddenly like,
"Dude, it's like Itachi."
And we're all like, "What?"
- Yeah, yeah.
I remember getting like mental whiplash,
like hearing this conversation.
- Where the fuck did that come from?
And then ordering a stuffed
crust pizza during recording.
Oh yeah.
- I think that is at like,
if you're technically speaking,
the strongest tangent.
- That is the strongest.
- We literally derailed
the episode to eat pizza.
- We literally.
- To discuss this.
We completely paused
the episode for a moment
so we could have hot dogs in crust.
- That is true.
- I think it's delicious,
it was delicious.
- That's the only,
that's a few times where
we've actually just ate
on an episode.
- I mean, I guess technically speaking.
yes, you're right, that
is the biggest tangent.
But we're not talking about-
- No the most winnable, yeah.
- No, we're not talking
about biggest tangent.
We're talking about best tangent.
And I think Itachi sacrifice.
- I think the Itachi sacrifice.
- Is by far my favorite tangent.
- I don't think it'll win.
- For me,
it's either that or the
eating the extinct tortoises.
- I think people really
enjoyed the tortoise bit.
- I think that was a good
bit, that was a good bit.
- It's true, I still want to eat one.
- All right, lets-
- But these are just random
conversations, I guess.
I just like the Itachi
sacrifice just came out nowhere,
and I hope that wins.
- Let's find out.
- All right, the best tangent,
as voted by you, the viewers, was,
I was right again, boys.
I'm fucking-
- What is it?
- Boys want to eat extinct tortoises.
- Oh wow.
- Oh, okay.
- How do I keep getting
it right? I know the fans.
I know you.
Why did you vote me as biggest clown?
No, fuck you all.
- Except when he has selective memory.
- Selective memory, yeah.
- I remember on the day.
- Do you remember what?
- That was a fun tangent.
That was a very fun tangent.
- I thought this was one of our,
even though I don't think
the views reflected it,
I think this is one of
our strongest episodes.
I remember I thought we
were just on point that day.
Like we had the-
- Everyone had jokes.
- Yeah, everyone just came out swinging.
I think we had the good discussion
about the deserted island
in the same episode as well.
- And the zombie apocalypse one.
- [Garnt] Yeah, the zombie apocalypse.
- I think we were just on point.
That was like one of my favorite episodes.
I don't think it got nominated
for best episode though,
but I think it one of my
favorite ones, if I recall.
- That is sad. I had a lot
of fun filming that episode.
- I think when we finished
that one, we were like,
we were just, "Yeah, we killed it."
We thought it was a good one.
- What was the percentage of that one?
- [Ashley] That one came in
first with 31.5% of the vote.
- Wow.
- Okay.
- Ooh, okay.
- That's quite a lot because
of how many clips there were.
- That's a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] In the second
place were the Turkish mafias,
I mean the taxi drivers,
with 16% of the vote.
- The taxi drivers, yeah.
- Okay yeah, I think I was gonna
say that was the other one.
- I think the Jan episode in general
was just like a really, really good.
I mean we were just like vibing with Jan,
and Jan spews the most random
shit all the time anyway.
- That's just Jan off camera as well.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Definitely, all right.
- [Ashley] You'll be happy to know
that third place was
your stuffed crust pizza,
with 14.2% of the vote.
- Oh really?
- Okay, okay.
- That's surprising actually.
Didn't think about that.
All right, next one though.
That's, best drip, who had it?
- It's gotta be me.
- Who had the drippiest drip?
I mean, I think I already know.
All right, let's find out
what the nominations are.
- Yes.
- Yeah, Connor drip jacket.
- Iconic.
- I mean,
I mean he bought it for that reason.
- I paid 2.000.
- Oh, okay.
- Why is Garnt's clown costume
and my banana clown costume in here?
That's what I don't understand.
- Okay, okay. Here's the
thing, here's the thing.
I think the clown costume
actually looked good with that
when I wasn't wearing
like the hat and the wig.
I remember I got a lot
of comments to be like,
"Yo, that doesn't actually look bad."
"It looks like really comfortable PJ's."
- [Connor] Dude, no, no.
- But it was like really comfortable PJ's.
- Was it like other clowns that said that?
They're all like, "Oh damn,
dude, looks better than mine."
And then Chris in a hat.
- [Connor] Of course.
- I have a feeling that's
gonna be a strong contender.
Calli's rapper costume, which
is actual drip, by the way.
And then Connor's TT/Apari merch.
- I think 'cause I'm always wearing.
- Oh yeah, true, true.
- I'm always wearing,
even off stream, off "Trash Taste,"
I'm always wearing the fucking shirt.
- I mean, Connor wears,
Connor wears three.
- I really, really don't
want the drip jacket to win.
- I don't want it to win.
- I am praying that you
all did a service today
and voted for the drip jacket.
- It's basically just winning
because, haha meme, you know?
- And it's funny, it's funny.
I laugh every time!
- Because people don't know,
Connor has three pieces of clothing.
The drip jacket, the Emiya
shirt and the TT merch.
That's all he fucking wears.
- Listen, listen, listen.
- That's the only clothes he owns.
- He literally-
- That's not drip.
- He literally bought the
drip just to win this award.
I know for a fact he bought
the drip to win this award.
- I spent an absurd amount of money
on a jacket that I can't
wear for most of the months
because it's way too fucking hot.
- He paid to win the best drip.
- And I better win.
I better fucking win.
- You know what?
I'm gonna be so happy
when Chris wins this.
- Yeah I, dude, I'm praying, I'm praying.
- Come on, baby, come on!
I'm betting big.
- Please, please.
- That Chris wins, ironically.
- I pray that Chris wins, ironically.
- 'Cause we're gonna get
a new saltiest moment
if Chris does win.
- All right.
Let's find out then.
The winner of the best drip,
according to the "Trash Taste" fans, is.
- Come on, come on, come
on, come on, come on.
- Chris in a hat.
- Yes!
- No!
(people cheering)
- No, this is.
- That's a standing ovation right there.
Standing ovation.
- This is collusion.
Stop the count.
I want a recount.
I'm calling out the Reddit,
I saw what they were doing.
- I knew, I knew "Trash
Taste" fans were good, man.
I knew you guys were great.
- I knew I had faith in you guys, man.
You guys are awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- I'm calling out the Reddit.
They colluded to do this.
- Thank you so much.
- If this was an honest
election, I would've fucking won.
Did I at least come second?
- [Ashley] Unfortunately, you did.
- Fuck!
- Wait, what were the percentages?
- [Ashley] Chris won
with 40.2% of the vote.
- [Connor] They colluded, they colluded.
- [Ashley] Connor came
in second with 30.1.
- [Connor] Collusion.
- See, you tried to pay to win, Connor.
- I can't beat-
- But as the gamer-
- I can't beat the mob!
- As the gamer, Connor,
you should know that doesn't work, Connor.
We're not EA here.
We're "Trash Taste".
- Just because you're a whale
doesn't mean you have the
best account, all right?
- We're a podcast of the people, Connor.
We can't be bought out by money.
Guys, you guys are awesome, guys.
You guys are awesome.
- Hell yeah.
- Fuck you guys.
- Thank you so much, guys.
- Fuck you.
- Thank you so much.
- [Garnt] Thank you so much.
- Good morrow, my fellow weebs and gamers.
It's your boy, Josh The Manga Lad,
here to let you know that
this episode of "Trash Taste"
is sponsored by Manscaped.
Watch out, the Manscaped
box is coming, ah!
You asked for it
and our friends over in
Manscaped have listened,
because they've brought back
the ultra smooth package.
Get hype.
And just for you guys,
you can get 20% off by using
our coupon code TrashTaste.
Oh my Lord. Well let me
tell you a little bit more
about the ultra smooth package.
Just in case you don't know.
The ultra smooth package
is a specialized growing and shaving kit
to help you buff, protect,
and smooth your most sensitive areas.
I'm talking crop shaver razors.
I'm talking crop exfoliator.
I'm talking crop gel.
Men, you no longer have to
borrow your ladies' stuff
to shave down there.
All three of these vegan, cruelty free,
and sulfate free products are included.
So you know your manhood is in good hands
and without compromise. So
what are you waiting for?
If you love deez nuts
just as I do, (chuckles)
then make sure to go to manscaped.com
and use our coupon code, TrashTaste,
to save 20% off your order.
That's 20% off with our
coupon code on screen.
Link's in the description below.
Thank you to manscaped for
sponsoring this episode.
Back to the show.
Deez nuts.
- Oh well, at least hopefully
I won't lose the next one.
- Yeah.
- All right, so the next
award is laziest drip.
Their mum buys all of their clothes.
- Well, Chris, Chris won
this one last year, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he did.
- Let's see, let's see.
- I mean, what are the
nominations for this one?
- Well, let's find out.
So we got Chris in a hat.
We got Connor's monkey costume.
Connor's "Trash Taste" hoodie.
I don't know about that.
That is drip.
That's our merch.
- Oh, well I think it's
'cause I wore it for-
- [Producer] 15 weeks in a row.
- It was laziest.
- Oh, laziest, I see.
- It's not worst drip,
it's laziest drip.
- Listen, I was trying
to represent the merch,
so I wore it 15 weeks in a row.
- [Joey] All right, and then Garnt, me,
and then Connor's Emiya shirt.
I love that half of these are Connor.
- How is my shirt lazy?
That is iconic.
I whipped that out on special occasions.
- I mean, the problem is here, right?
As, I, of course,
I think out of here, I
think Chris is going to win.
because Connor has three
nominations for this one.
- [Joey] True.
That's spread out between three, right?
- [Garnt] Spread out between three, right?
- No, no, no, Chris is gonna win
'cause I saw everyone online
colluding to make sure Chris won.
- Because here's the thing, Connor.
The award is laziest drip, right?
- Yeah.
- Your Emiya shirt has been
nominated two years in a row.
- And I didn't lose last year
and I'm not gonna lose again.
How is my monkey costume lazy drip?
- I mean, it's barely clothes.
It's a costume.
- How was Garnt's clown
costume in best drip,
but my monkey costume is in laziest drip?
- Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, I never noticed that.
- How does that make any fucking sense?
Viewers, the viewers have
half a brain cell, I think.
All right.
Garnt, who's the winner?
- Let's just find out, I guess.
- All right.
- I think we know who it's gonna be.
- I think we all know who it's gonna be.
- The laziest drip is,
to complete the circle, Chris in a hat.
- Yeah.
- Yay.
(people applauding)
- So like, that's like a
plus minus zero, right?
So he doesn't get an award at all?
- So he doesn't get on award at all.
- Sorry Chris.
Oh, my bad.
Shouldn't have worn that hat, dude.
- All right, well I guess next up.
- I love, I love the hat.
I want him to wear it again.
- I actually won a Curious George monkey
that actually wears the exact same hat.
- Really?
- I want to give him a skateboard.
You know, I want to give him skateboard
so he can like recreate the
hello, for the children image.
- I would pay to see that.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- All right, won?
- Chris, please, please.
I'm begging, I'm begging.
- How much do you win by 90%?
- [Ashley] Chris won that
with 50.5% of the vote.
- Oh wow.
- Who came second, actually?
- [Ashley] Connor's "Trash Taste" hoodie.
- Oh, okay, yeah.
- 32.8%.
- 15 years in a row.
- 15 years?
- That's a good quality.
Hey, you can work 15 weeks in a row
without washing it, by the way.
- Exactly, that's just the test.
- Filthiest drip.
- I know.
So next up is one that's near
and dear to all our hearts.
It's the next, the next,
sorry, I can't English.
The next nomination is the
best rant of "Trash Taste."
- Ooh.
- [Joey] We had a lot of those as well.
- There's a lot.
Okay, here's the thing.
I'm not sure what was nominated.
I can't remember.
But what's the difference between a rant
and an argument, right?
Because I'm-
- A rant is when you go
on probably on your own.
- Yeah, a rant is like a
one sided, just like, spiel.
- Where you all agree or like
it's one long fucking tirade.
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
- All right, let's see
what the nominations are.
- Best rant.
- [Joey] Garnt got trolled
by a Japanese bank.
- Yeah, like this isn't
an argument, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I love this one, okay.
We can't call anime "mid" anymore.
That was.
- I mean, I mean,
yeah, we all.
- That was like a collective rant, I feel.
- Yeah, that was a collective rant.
And Joey got the brunt of it.
- I got the brunt of it.
'Cause I said the word, apparently.
We do not support NFTs.
Still stand by it.
- I want that one to win.
- All right, all right.
- Still stand by it.
Ranting about "Jump King" with Mori.
- Was that a rant?
- Was that a rant.
- [Producer] It's a rant.
- That was, I wouldn't
say that was a rant.
- The viewers decided it was.
- What's the clip of this?
Can we see the clip of
why this counts as a rant?
What is "Jump King?"
Oh yeah, yeah, we should do it together.
Oh, you've done it, oh, you've done it?
Yeah, I've done it as well.
- Go on, take a wild guess
what you do in "Jump King."
- Do you jump?
- You're a king,
and you jump!
- You jump!
You jump up, Garnt.
- I would like to try streaming that.
- Okay.
- Give it a shot.
See how far you get.
- Don't get,
don't get my hopes up like that, Garnt.
- All right,
that's a rant because no
one would answer my question
of what was "Jump King."
And I asked like two times
or something, I think.
- Yeah, true. And then Garnt
learns the Dead Sea is a lake.
- [Connor] Which we saw earlier, as well.
- [Garnt] Yeah, what you saw earlier.
- NFTs, I want NFTs to win.
- I really want the NFTs one to win,
but I have a feeling it's gonna be the,
"We can't call anime "mid" anymore."
- Probably, probably.
- I just have a feeling.
- I want NFTs to win.
'Cause I can continue ranting about NFTs.
- It's the one time I want NFTs to win.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Let's find out.
- It's the one time
I'm supporting NFTs.
- Yeah, come on.
- This is the one time.
- Well, if we have to know,
it's Garnt learns the Dead Sea is a lake.
- Are you serious?
- Okay, okay, okay.
- Wow, all right, all right.
That's-
- I mean, I mean,
I mean, I was very salty at the moment.
I feel like at least it
got some representation.
- [Joey] Look at that fucking
side eye you're giving to.
That just tells the
whole story right there.
- He's fuming, boys.
- What's?
- I mean, I feel like this
was probably the most.
- It's pretty close, this one.
- Yeah, the most emotional rant.
- Definitely.
- Audio wise.
- What were the percentages?
- [Ashley] This was
pretty close all around.
Garnt won that with 28.5% of the vote.
- Ooh, okay.
- [Ashley] Second place
was him getting trolled
by a Japanese bank with 21.9% of the vote.
Oh no, sorry.
Second was "We can't
call anime "mid" anymore"
with 22% of the vote.
- Awesome, awesome.
- Thereabouts the same.
Third was the Japanese bank,
and NFTs came in fourth
with 17.4% of the vote.
- Fair enough.
- Damn, all right.
- All right, all right, all right.
- We definitely remember
those rants differently
to the rest of the audience.
- What's up next, Joey?
- All right.
- I think us ranting about NFTs
has just like gone throughout, you know?
- 'Cause we've done it so many times.
- We've done it so many times, yeah.
- Next one though.
Oh, this one's also hot,
near and dear to our heart.
Best argument.
- Ooh.
- Ooh!
- [Joey] So this time
it's a two-sided rant.
- Yes.
- Essentially.
- That is technically it.
- It's an opposing, two-sided rant.
- Yes.
- Yeah, we had a lot of those.
- Which one's we choose from.
- Yeah, right?
- Oh my God.
How many arguments did we have this year?
A lot.
- A lot.
- And we continue doing so.
- Let's say what the nominations are.
The great chicken debate.
- The great chicken debate.
- Oh that was this year, wasn't it?
- Holy fuck.
- Oh my God.
That feels like an eternity ago.
- That was in this studio.
Holy fuck.
- Yeah.
That was like right
when we moved, I think.
- That was like the week
after we moved in, I think.
- [Joey] I think, yeah.
. And we were just like,
can we top any of the
arguments in season one?
And then we immediately come in
with like the great chicken debate.
- I wanna clarify, people to this day,
still think I don't eat bone in chicken.
I do, I just prefer boneless.
- Still a clown, you're still a clown.
- Yeah, no, no.
- Yeah.
- I like bone in chicken.
I just prefer bone out.
- I'm glad I'm sitting
on this side right now.
I'm glad I'm sitting on this side.
- I hang out people who like
watch "Trash Taste" sometimes.
Like I met them, they'll be like,
"Oh, you sure you're okay
eating that bone in chicken?"
I'm like, "What the fuck?"
Yes, I don't give a fuck.
I would just prefer if there was no bones.
- Exactly.
- Dude, you deserve that.
You deserve that.
- No, I don't deserve that.
- You both deserve that.
- No, no, no, no.
- You both, shut up, shut up.
- The great-
- Do we need a clip of this?
- Actually, I wanna see what Mudan cut,
how Mudan cut this again?
I'm so curious just to see
how we cut this together.
- Boneless.
- No, boneless, man.
- Boneless, Boneless.
- I'm a boneless kind guy, man.
I'm a boneless kinda guy.
- Get that bone outta there.
If I can't eat it, get it outta my face.
- Sometimes I just don't
wanna go through the process
of being like a fucking animal
and tearing the shit limb from limb.
- Thank you.
- It tastes better.
- I'm not-
- I just wanna-
- No it doesn't, bro.
- It tastes better.
- You're full of shit,
you're full of shit.
(people chattering)
- You're like try to play
(indistinct) with this chicken.
- What are you talking about?
- You are full of shit.
- This is like one of the few times
where all three of us are
talking at the same time.
- I just realized how much
of a Karen I sounded there.
- You are a Karen.
- It tastes better.
- You are.
'Cause it does, I was just like,
"You guys have made me do
something I've never done before,"
"which is go full Karen," you know?
- Go full Karen.
And honestly-
- I was like, "Call the manager."
"Meilyne, get here right now."
- [Joey] All right,
then we also have obviously
the great pizza debate.
That one, I mean,
this is another two versus one argument.
- It's true, it's true.
- [Joey] And then Connor thinks
he definitely bought an Eva.
- I did, I did.
- Oh this, okay.
So the last two are
from the figure special,
which there were certainly a
lot of crowning arguments of.
And then all Among Us are the same.
- True.
- That was one of my
favorite arguments I think.
- Oh yeah.
I just love how angry Connor got.
I'm like, you do realize you're fuming
over fucking "Among Us" right now?
- I realize all of these
arguments are like me,
being like, having to
argue my fucking side.
- All of these are you being difficult.
- I'm not being difficult.
You're on my side for this one.
What you talking about?
- No, I was in the middle fucking.
- No you weren't.
Don't act like you, what are
you, Italy in World War II?
"I was in the middle."
- I was average chicken
enjoyer right there.
I was like, "I can go both, bro."
"I don't give a fuck."
- No, I'm not letting you
get away with that, Joey.
I am not letting.
Because-
- Come on, man.
Let me off the hook.
- Joey comes in, 'cause like this is,
this isn't in the worst food takes, right?
Because it was so overshadowed
by the rest of the chicken debate
that I remember being like
"Bone in chicken's the same."
And Joey was like, "Not
all chicken is the same."
And it that just erupted
the fucking argument.
And then he just like stepped out.
He stepped out.
- "All chicken's the same."
"All right, see ya."
- I think the chicken one
will win, but I don't know.
- I'm pretty sure.
- I think the chicken one is-
- I think the chicken
one is the most iconic.
- [Joey] Definitely.
- And-
- Has lasting impact to this day.
- And I'm still, we're still
arguing it to this day.
Like honestly, like great pizza debate,
I'm like, whatever.
Connor can think what he thinks.
Like he's just like wrong.
You guys are just wrong in
the great chicken debate.
Like you guys are just wrong.
- Oh, you know, whatever, whatever.
All right, who won?
- You're just wrong.
I'm sorry.
- All right,
let's find out then.
Then the best argument
of "Trash Taste" 2022 is,
the great chicken debate.
- Naturally.
- Woo!
- Not even surprised by that.
- That shouldn't even be close.
- It's not sorted to this day.
I'm still not happy about
the result of the argument.
- I will guess it won by
like 50% plus or something.
- [Ashley] 50.6.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Not even surprised by that.
- I'm such.
- Do you know my favorite
moment of this argument
is at the end, me and
Connor were just like,
we hand shook about both being clowns,
and then we were immediately afterwards
go back into arguing.
It's like, you shook hands
and then it was like,
"I still hate you."
- "You're still wrong though."
"Fuck you, dude."
- All right, what's next up, Garnt?
- Next up is,
so as you know, with "Trash Taste",
we have a lot of food takes.
- Oh God.
- And we have a lot of bad food takes.
So the next award is to
reward our worst food takes.
- I mean, to be honest,
I don't even have to see the nominations.
- I know who's won this one.
- All bread tastes the same.
- Okay, okay. I will just have to say
that obviously that was a bad food take,
but there have been some
outrageous food takes this year.
- Well let's see. Let's see
what the nominations are.
- Like we-
- Let's see what the nominations are.
- We are-
- Eh, just look at the nominations, Garnt.
- We are truly living
up to our names here.
- All right, so cereal
is better without milk.
- That's a-
- Okay, I stand by that.
- Garnt, Garnt.
- 90% Bread tastes the same.
All rice tastes the same.
- [Garnt] That's Joey?
- That was just me misphrasing
what I was trying to say, okay?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- All Japanese rice.
- Sure, sure Joey.
Sure Joey, sure Joey, sure sure.
- All Japanese rice tastes the same.
- I actually understand him.
I think most Japanese
rice does taste the same.
- All Japanese rice tastes the same.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- I can obviously tell difference
between fucking Japanese
rice and basmati rice, okay?
I'm not bad dead in the tongue.
New York pizza is better
than stone baked pizza.
- How is this a worst food take?
- No, no.
- That was, that's pretty shit.
- What?
- Also your canned tuna
tastes better than fresh tuna.
- Why is there nothing?
This is just-
- It's like, you don't even get-
- That doesn't even deserve a clip, man.
That doesn't even deserve a clip.
- I think it has a taste
to it that is nice.
- That was so bad.
- It's very nice.
- That's so bad.
And then chewy steak is
like meat flavored gum.
- That was Meilyne.
That was Meilyne.
- Oh, that was Meilyne.
Okay.
- Yeah.
That just came out of nowhere.
I was just like, "You said what?"
- [Joey] Okay, so there's two Garnt,
two Connor, one me, one Meilyne.
- Well, I know who's gonna win.
Congratulations, Garnt, on your award.
- Yep, yep, Just say it,
just say it right now.
- We're gonna award it to yourself.
- Just say it right now. What is it?
- And the worst food take is,
New York pizza is, nah,
it's fucking bread.
(men laughing)
- I was like, "Oh my God,
the viewers are clowns."
- I saw, I saw Connor's jaw
literally drop for a second there.
- I was like, "No fucking way."
- I was like, "All the
Europeans missed this one."
That's for sure.
All right, how much did a win by?
- 48.9%.
- Holy shit.
Fucking hell.
- What came in second and
third, out of curiosity?
- [Ashley] Cereal is better
without milk, came in second.
- What?
- Garnt, congratulations on
having the worst food taste
in "Trash Taste".
- Those are double,
two doubles.
- Congratulations.
- That was, that's a legit.
- I stand by that.
- That's top two.
Cereal is better without the milk.
- [Ashley] Third was,
chewy steak is like meat flavored gum.
- Wow, we weren't even in the top three.
- We weren't even in the top three.
- I guess our food takes are good, eh?
- Hell yeah, thanks guys.
- I can't believe it, I can't believe it.
- Thanks guys.
- Thank you viewers.
- All right, what's the next one, Connor?
- All right, next up is, you know,
you've heard the worst food takes.
- Mm-hm.
- What about the best poop moment?
Two sides of the same coin.
- Only on the "Trash Taste Awards"
will you have an award
called the best poop award.
- We talk about poop a lot.
I don't know how, I don't know how.
- I'm surprised we have
the category for this,
but apparently we do.
- What was the tagline you used to say
for "Trash Taste" again?
The podcast where we
talk about food, anime,
food, poop and occasionally anime.
- Yeah, yeah.
Did I say that?
- Yeah, that was you.
- How do you remember that?
- I dunno, 'cause it just stuck by me.
I'm like, it's so out there.
- It's true, it's true.
- So what are the nominations?
- Let's see.
- Yes.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, me
sniffing cat poop in a sock.
Yep, that's just Meilyne getting me there.
We got, have you ever coughed
and shit at the same time?
That's also me.
- That's like best out of
context moment as well.
Can we see, can we see
these clips, actually?
I wanna see these clips.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Mudan] Oh yeah, want to
start from the first one?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have a very suspicious sock.
(Joey sniffing)
- Meilyne put cat shit in that sock?
- You were sniffing cat shit!
- What?
(men laughing)
- I couldn't fucking believe it.
- She's crazy.
- I got paid,
I got paid to sniff cat shit.
- She brought cat shit from her house.
- Yeah.
- To the office.
On a train.
Public transport.
- That's what I was more
like offended about.
The fact that you would do that.
- [Connor] Joey, I don't
even know why you said this.
- Have you ever coughed
and shit at the same time?
- No, what, what?
- We're not talking about shitting yet.
Yet.
- Yeah.
All right, I'll leave it for the one.
- What do you have a story, Joey?
- No.
- Fuck.
(men laughing)
- Good clip, good clip.
- I legitimately don't though.
That's the thing.
- Then why did you bring it up?
- I was just curious.
- [Connor] Kson talks about
pooping and video games.
This is to do with Ark, I believe.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
Play this clip.
- Ark is really famous for pooping.
It really is.
Just Google Ark and poop.
- Why?
- Are you sure Ark is famous for pooping
or are you trying to make it famous?
Are you trying to make
it famous for pooping?
- Just Google it right now?
Ark, poop.
- I've just seen compilations of Vtubers
reacting to dinosaurs pooping in Ark,
and they just like lose their mind.
- What a compilation.
- Is that a thing?
- Yeah.
- This was like a Chef Mac
moment where we were just like,
we did not tell her to talk,
start talking about poop.
We tried our best to not talk about poop
because we had a guest on.
- This was like if they
knew the assignment.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, right?
- [Joey] And then we also have
why Garnt spends 30 minutes on the toilet.
- You actually genuinely
take 30 minutes to shit.
- We get to the point in this office
where I legitimately go, "Where's Garnt?"
- Yeah, we go, "Where's Garnt?"
And we realize he's been
gone for 30 minutes.
- Did he go to the shops or something?
No, he's taking a shit.
Are you performing like alchemy in there?
Like why is it taking so long?
- Ah, they didn't show it in this clip,
but it's the part where Garnt's like,
"I just don't feel satisfied
until I'm completely empty."
- I still stand by that, man.
It's just like, you
need, once you go poop,
you need to get it all out.
Otherwise, why are you sitting down?
You know, why are you sitting down?
- [Connor] Guessing this
is the origin of the poop.
- I guess now-
- Oh okay.
- [Garnt] We've found it out.
- All right, let's play it.
Say it's like this, right?
- Yeah.
- Right?
I'm like, okay, close the lid, flush.
And then I do this while it's flushing.
- But your pants are down, right?
- No.
- Well then that's the exact same thing.
- Well no, 'cause,
as I'm getting up,
I kind of like pull it up
to the point of it's there,
but I just gotta zip
it up and do the belt.
You know, you understand what I mean?
You understand what I mean, right?
- No.
- Why was this a conversation?
- I remember it was the day
before we had this episode,
I had this thing where the
guy like flushed the toilet
and then immediately left
the toilet and I thought,
"Huh, that guy must have done everything"
"and then flushed the toilet
and immediately walked out."
And I was like-
- Right, right, right.
- And I was like, "Does everyone do that?"
'Cause I always like,
I flush the toilet the moment I stand up.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was just like, "I
wonder if I'm the same?"
So I guess that's why it came out.
- Oh, there you go.
There's the origin.
- That was a pretty deep
conversation regarding poop.
- [Connor] Yeah, that was bad.
- 'Cause I remember we had
like a 30 minute conversation
just breaking down poop technique.
- I remember if like 15 minutes
we were talking about like,
do you wipe from the
front or from the back?
- Oh.
- Like, ugh.
- Well let's find out who the winner is.
- Oh who do you want to win?
- I want me sniffing cat poop.
- Yeah, Joey sniffy cat shit.
- It's either, both of them are Joey.
Have you cough and shit at the same time?
Such a fucking good clip as well.
- I'm just the poop man.
- Well the winner is,
Joey sniffs cat shit in a sock.
- Yeah!
- You know, I'll fucking take that.
I'll take, I'm proud of that one.
- Well deserved, well deserved.
- I did it for the boys.
- Thank you very much, Meilyne.
For possibly,
I think making the most
unintentionally memorable ad read
that we've ever done.
'Cause that was an ad read.
- Yeah, it was, yeah.
- Yeah it was.
- I'm sure LaVoy was
thrilled with that one.
What were the percentages?
(Connor burps)
- Sorry.
- [Ashley] Cat shit won
with 39% of the vote.
- Oh damn.
- Hell yeah.
- [Ashley] And Joey coughing and shitting
won with 20, came in second
with 21.9% of the vote.
- Very good, very good.
- That's all we need to know,
that's all we need to know.
- All is well, all is well.
- I got the top two, I'll take that.
I'll take that.
- All right,
next category, Joey, what is it?
- All right, next category is,
ooh, this one's a new one
as well for this year.
- This is my favorite one.
- [Joey] The most privileged moment.
- Oh, oh.
So, you know-
- The most privileged moment.
- I think the biggest
difference from last year
and this year is that we
have found out how big
a podcast could become.
We didn't really know that last year.
So you know, you might have seen a, yeah.
What was that conversation
we've ad where it was like,
"You've changed," right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, this is that award.
- It's that you've changed award.
- The you've changed award.
- What are the nominations though?
- [Joey] We got Sydsnap
doesn't wanna be called poor.
- [Connor] Oh yeah, that's a good story.
- I think I'm just like,
yeah, because at this point,
Connor keeps calling me poor
and it's like, honestly,
at any time I could get
something where I'm like,
I'm not poor.
- But that, that's such a
long in-joke explanation.
Sydney would hate it when
I used to call her poor,
so I used to always call
her poor to piss her off.
- That's like precedes "Trash Taste."
- This is a very, very long running thing.
- Where was I?
- You were in the toilet, I guess.
- Oh, I was pooping, okay, okay, okay.
- You were in the toilet
for 30 minutes, yeah.
- Okay, okay, okay.
That makes lot sense.
I was like, "When the
fuck did this happen?"
"I do not remember this."
- [Joey] Then Garnt's quarantine, oh.
- [Connor] This one, this one, this one.
- They go, "Yeah, I'm really sorry."
And I'm like, "Okay, maybe
we do need to get two rooms."
And they're like, "Yeah,
I'm really sorry."
"All the king size beds are gone."
"This one only has a queen size bed."
(people laughing)
And I'm like, and then they're like.
- What?
Bro, you're getting a five star experience
and I'm out here fighting for my life.
- This is a hotel I would
stay in if I was on holiday.
We walk in and there's a hallway
that leads to our bed, right?
And then, so we walk in,
where me and Sydney look at each other
and I'm just like, "The
gotcha Gods are on my side!"
I think what makes this even better
is just knowing that Connor-
- The juxtaposition, right?
- That Connor stayed in
like a peasant hotel.
Like I, I love it, I love it.
- That's so good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] And then Connor spent $1,000
on the Goku drip jacket.
- I'd do it again, I'd do it again.
- Very privileged.
- Very, extremely privileged.
- He bought this just
to win the best drip,
and he didn't win.
- He didn't even win that.
- I didn't buy it to win best drip.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- I bought it because it's iconic.
- No, you absolutely want
it for the best drip.
- No, no, no.
I wanted it 'cause I wanted it.
It's an iconic meme history piece.
- Oh you got steal,
Connor, you got a steal.
It's only a thousand bucks.
- Only a thousand bucks.
- Wow.
- [Garnt] And then there's
the boys go into playing golf.
- Oh, this is privileged?
- Is this privileged?
- I guess so.
- Calling out every golf player now.
- What the fuck?
- No, because I recently got
back into golf and I was like,
"My God, that is the most
boomer thing I've ever done."
- See, I don't think
golf is a boomer thing.
I feel like-
- It's a privilege thing.
- I don't think it's-
- That's the difference.
- It's a privileged boomer thing.
- If you're broke, you
can't be playing golf.
That's just facts.
- That's true.
- Okay.
- Okay yeah, okay, that makes sense.
We utter the word privilege in this clip,
so I guess that makes sense.
- [Garnt] And then there's
Connor complaints about
his free quarantine meals.
- Dude, this, these meals were shit.
These meals were abhorrent.
I don't even have good taste.
- Because this one wasn't even controversy
that was like started on the podcast.
It was controversy that
was started on Twitter
by Connor posting his like image.
- It had to be done, right?
- And then the meals were crap, right?
- Oh my God.
- You guys sent me pictures of the meals.
- No, yeah, I got,
I posted one of them and I was like,
"This is the saddest breakfast ever"
and it caused like a
fucking argument on Twitter.
- I'm like, "You almost got
canceled on Twitter for that."
"Didn't you?"
- Everyone was like, people are like,
"Man, Connor's privilege is
acting up so much recently.
People are acting like
I fucking went to like to eat in school
and went to Cambridge because
I said one meal was shit.
People need to get the
fuck over themselves.
- I hope that one wins.
- I gotta say, 'cause like,
just looking at that
image, I was just like,
"That's a very aesthetic image for like."
- Yeah, I was like, "That looks good."
- It's aesthetic if I'm going
to the fucking kid store
to get a Playmobile set of fake food.
It's fucking shit.
It's all cold and hard.
So bad.
- It's just the way that,
even with like the worst
meals they can serve,
they still serve like really
good aesthetic looking meals.
I want that to win.
Just like the dichotomy
of just Connor going,
"This shit, this shit."
- "This shit."
- And the picture actually
looking pretty damn good.
- Well, let's find out then.
- All right, all right.
- Let's find out the
most privileged moment-
- Ah fuck, that's gonna win.
- Of the "Trash Taste" awards is,
Connor spent $1,000 on
the Goku drip jacket.
- I'll take that.
That's the privilege I want.
That's the kind of privilege
I need around here.
It was a bit more than
a thousand, actually.
It was like $1,500 or something.
- That's pretty privileged.
- That is absolutely privileged.
- I mean it's all privilege.
Who, who topped the charts for that one?
- Top three, what's top three?
- [Ashley] Ooh, all top
three were all pretty close.
Connor won that one
with 26.1% of the vote.
- Ooh, that was close.
- Fucking hell.
- [Ashley] Sydsnap came in
second with 25.7% of the vote.
- Well done, Sydney, well done.
- Wow, nearly privileged.
- [Ashley] And in third place
was Garnt's quarantine hotel
with 22.1% of the vote.
- Ooh, okay.
- Privileged Garnt.
- [Joey] Damn.
- Well, I guess you can
still call Sydney poor then,
because she's less
privileged than you, Connor.
- Yeah, Sydney's poor.
Sydney, you're poor.
- She's the second most
privileged on "Trash Taste".
- You're poor.
All right, next up, Garnt.
What is it?
- Next up is,
so we talk a lot of shit on "Trash Taste."
- Oh, this is the one
I've been waiting for.
It's my favorite.
- We talk a lot of shit,
and we might not always,
fact check what we way.
- Fact check.
- So this is the, "I made
it the fuck up" award.
Where, I'm glad that we are not part
of the scientific community
where we have to cite our sources.
Because 90% of the time,
we never have sources.
- I'm glad people don't
take this show seriously.
Because my God.
- Yeah.
So what are the nominations for this one?
- Let's find out.
(men laughing)
All right, starting off strong.
Oh my God, all of these.
2021 anime wasn't good.
- That was definitely like,
I made it the fuck up.
- You know what, I'll admit to that.
I definitely made this the fuck up.
- That came back to bite you so hard.
- That came back to bite me so hard.
- 'Cause everyone used
that to discredit you.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Your opinions.
- Pretty much.
- 'Cause I remember, cause like,
I don't remember when
you said this, but I was,
'cause I was like, "I watched 2021 anime."
"I fucking love 2021 anime."
So when this got spread
around, I was like,
"Did Joey say that?"
"I definitely would've given
him shit if he said that."
- I was surprised.
I think I remember still,
I was surprised with the lack
of shit I got on the episode.
You guys were kind of just
like, "Hmm, is that right?"
And then that was it.
- I don't watch any of it.
How would I know?
- Yeah, right?
And then we have from "After Dark,"
we have fish don't exist.
- That's still true.
You can Google it.
I just explained it poorly.
- That was just like a poor explanation.
- Poor explanation.
- [Joey] This one, wasn't
a poor explanation.
Food poisoning isn't an illness.
- [Connor] I still stand
by this to this day.
- No, man.
- I still don't treat food poisoning
as an illness in my mind.
It's, you're poisoned.
- That's just, that's just dumb.
- Whatever, whatever.
- Are you a doctor, are you a doctor?
- I don't give a fuck.
- I would like to know
what doctors think of this.
- I don't give a fuck
what the doctors think.
- [Joey] Well, I'm definitely
not a psychologist,
because I thought introverts
are incapable of being social.
Which is just like-
- I remember when like,
Jan said the most wild
shit in this episode,
but somehow they still got more offended
that Joey said this.
Jan literally said like so
many misogynist comments
and then this was the one
they had a problem with.
- Yeah, Jan was just like, "So yeah,"
"here's the entire dark world"
"of the fucking host club world."
"A lot of shady things going on."
- [Joey] And then I was just-
- "Introverts aren't
capable of being social."
What the fuck?
- Just pause the episode.
That's where i draw the line, I'm done.
- 'Cause the thing that
stands out about this
is that out of all of these, right?
I think this was the only one
where like I like
corrected you for that one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause I think I
actually did correct you
for that one.
- You were trying to correct
me to the best of your ability,
but I wasn't-
- You just like weren't having it.
- I remember I folded pretty
quickly on the introverts one.
'Cause I realized what I said, right?
But the 2021 one,
everyone was like-
- No, that's-
- "Is that right?"
- You know what?
just says a lot about me
that as much as food
poisoning isn't an illness
is like an outrageous and just,
like you talk to a doctor,
it's just factually wrong.
You know, it's like you've
turned a factually wrong thing
into just like a feeling now.
- [Connor] It's a feeling.
- I still gotta go with 2021.
- I still think it's 2021 anime.
- I'm surprised, there's
some other funny moments.
I remember when I said that like
Pokemon was the most
Googled thing in 1996.
And Google didn't exist in 1996.
I'm surprised that wasn't on there.
- Oh yeah!
- I think it's because we did like-
- It's because we were
all like, "Oh really?"
- Yeah, I think that one wasn't brought up
because it was just you,
it was just an out of context line.
Because it was just like,
I remember hearing that
and I remember thinking,
"That doesn't sound right,"
"but my knowledge isn't good enough"
"to try and argue that fact."
- Am I crazy?
It was the most Googled
thing in one of the years.
I can't remember which year it was though.
- It definitely wasn't 1996.
- It was a shame, 'cause she was like,
"You had the right meaning,
just fucked up the execution."
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- 'Cause I feel like a lot more lines
that were just passed
over weren't nominated,
and I can't remember them.
- Yeah, true.
- I remember there has been
plenty of plenty of moments
where we've stopped recording
and then we've realized
what we said the day after,
and we were just like,
"Why did no one challenge me on this?"
And we were like, "Well
we didn't know either."
- 'Cause all of us are just
like, "I guess you're right."
"He said it with such confidence."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, right?
- All right, what's
the winner of this one?
- You know what?
I hope I win this one with the 2021 anime.
- I made it the fuck up award goes to,
2021 anime wasn't any good.
- Yeah!
You know what?
I can't even defend myself on that
'cause I didn't watch
anything the 2021, bro.
- Joey literally made it the fuck up.
- I made it the fuck up.
- That was the most "I
made it the fuck up."
- That was "I definitely
What were the percentages though?
- [Ashley] Wasn't even close 46.9%.
- 47?
- 46.9%.
What was second?
- [Ashley] Connor's food
poisoning came in at-
- I thought that was
gonna be strong contender.
- [Ashley] Second with 29%.
- Oh my God.
Well, sorry, not sorry, I guess.
- All right.
- Well next up,
the best "Trash Taste After Dark" episode.
- Ooh.
- Oh, we're getting to the big awards now.
- Okay, well, you know,
obviously this year we really put our foot
onto "After Dark."
- I think I know what's gonna win this.
Can we see the nominations?
- All right, let's see.
- [Connor] That thumbnail.
- [Joey] I still love that thumbnail.
- [Connor] The one where
we try American snacks.
The one where we rate beers.
The one, the figure special.
The-
- Fifth grader.
- The fifth grade.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] Next slide.
The UNO one, which is very popular.
The role playing one, amazing stream.
And of course, the 24 hour stream.
- The charity stream.
- Yes.
- Oh man, all of these are
such great episodes though.
- [Garnt] Yes.
- I mean, I think it's
obvious which one's gonna win.
- You think?
- I mean, I think it's gonna
be the 24-Hour charity stream.
- I think, I would bet
my entire life savings
on that this is gonna win.
- Really?
- Yeah, but like-
- Would you not?
- I don't know.
They're like all good,
but for different reasons.
I mean obviously with the recency.
- I mean, this is five episodes in one.
- It's also the message, you know?
This is like, we raised money for charity.
- We raised money.
We did a good thing.
- That is true, that is true.
- You know, we went
just like, (indistinct)
- I guess of course it's like also
the recency bias as well, right?
- Maybe, yeah.
I just think it was a really night.
- And also there were just so many
fucking amazing moments from these.
We got all of the best
out of context clips
and out of context moments.
I think it's like,
I would be interested to see
what do you think would come second?
- I personally really like the TLPG one.
- That was like one of the funnest TT,
that was one of the funnest
"Trash Taste After Darks"
I had to film as well.
- Like everyone was on point.
Like, you know, Karen
was like top of a game.
You know, everyone was hilarious.
- It was so great because
it was just so on point
to KonoSuba as well.
Like it was literally like
I watched back and I'm like,
"Yeah, damn, we just made
a "KonoSuba" episode,"
"just like live."
And I'm just like, "How
did we do this unscripted?"
- I also named my character after the mum
from the hentai masterpiece
and no one noticed.
- Oh yeah, that's right.
- But like I, yeah, I mean a
quick word about "After Dark."
I would have to say, I think even,
there's a point where I think
if you don't watch "After Dark,"
I actually think some of our
best content out this year
came from "After Dark," you know?
I think because I think initially
we didn't have "After Dark"
until the second half the year
and a lot of effort, a lot
of our time and effort,
was put into making "After
Dark" the best that it could be.
You know, you could argue
sometimes we focus on that more
than the main show at times
because that's how much we
wanted it to get off the ground.
So, you know, if you
don't watch "After Dark,"
please watch the vods. There
are a lot of great moments,
and some of the best moments
of this year in "After Dark."
- Absolutely, absolutely.
But there can only be one winner though.
Let's find out.
(Garnt making drum roll sounds)
24 hour stream.
- Of course.
- Well done, well done.
- Okay, very nice.
- Well deserved, well deserved.
I mean, it still blows my mind
how much was raised that day.
- [Connor] Oh yeah.
- I remember, 'cause I remember
thinking we set the goal
at 100k, and about five hours in,
I was like, "We've made
a massive mistake."
- Yeah, "We're not gonna hit it."
"We're not gonna that."
And then cum comes out of
the woodworks and is like,
"Let me help you."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh man.
- So yeah, what was the
percentage breakdown of that?
- [Ashley] Ooh, 49.7% went to
the 24 hour charity stream.
- Not surprising.
- [Ashley] Second place
was the TRPG stream.
- Yep, okay.
- 15.1%.
- All right, that makes so much sense.
- Totally got that right.
- All right, what's the
next category, Joey?
- All right, well, third to last.
We have, oh, okay,
this one of as well is a new one and is,
I think mostly "After Dark" related,
but we've done a lot of quizzes.
- Ooh.
- On "After Dark."
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
- And we've had some pretty
fucking monkey moments,
so it's the dumbest quiz answer.
- So yeah, we've had a lot of, I guess,
dumb answers on the quizzes, right?
- On the quizzes I was either
like insane or just boosted.
There was never an in
between on the quizzes.
- This is, I mean like the quiz,
this is like a new category
for this year, right?
- Yeah, definitely.
- So we wanted some representation
for some of the new content
that we started making this year.
- [Joey] Some representation
for "After Dark."
- So I think we should show these moments,
because I think a lot of people
wouldn't have seen these moments
because they didn't watch "After Dark."
- Yeah, let's go.
Let's check out the nominations.
- Let's check out the nominations.
- [Joey] Well, obviously we
got Connor spells "nghaw."
Play the clip, actually.
- Play the clip.
- Oh, this is easy
- Oh, N-G-H-A-W.
- What?
- Yeah.
- No.
- What?
- What the fuck?
- [Joey] Say that again.
- N-G-H-A-W, is not gnaw?
- My moment of silence says it all.
- I think he was just like the,
'cause it was like a moment
silence after he said that.
and it was just like everyone in the room
was just processing what he said.
- Like, "Could you repeat that?"
- Not my proudest moment,
not my proudest moment.
- 'Cause I remember Joey,
you couldn't even hold in your laughter.
You're just like, (chuckles), "Could you?"
- I thought you were joking at first.
I was like, "No, that
was a mistake, right?"
- It was just like the extreme
confidence he said it in.
- It's like, "Oh, N-G-H-A-W."
- Yeah, yeah.
- I just, for some reason
I had the blinders on.
I was so convinced that's
how you spelled it.
- So good, so good.
- Can't for the life of me explain why.
There we go.
- [Joey] And then we obviously have
the boys give Budweiser a 7.5/10.
- [Garnt] We've already seen this one.
- [Joey] We've already seen
that one. The baby one time.
That was from the music quiz, I believe.
Play the clip.
- I put "baby" and "one more time,"
but I put stuff before it.
So sure if Garnt gets it-
- Not to mention, you
wrote "Baby one time."
- Oh shit.
- Also, if Garnt-
- "Baby one time!"
- I'm sorry, but if
Garnt is getting a point,
I deserve a point as well.
- No, he doesn't get a point for that.
He said "Baby one time."
- Nice, nice, nice.
- All right, I will say, I will say,
I got dicked over in
this quiz, by the way,
because it was the staff that said to me
the song name was "Hit
Me Baby One More Time."
The official name is "Baby One More Time."
I was just too fucking monkey
to spell it out properly, okay?
- [Joey] Baby one time.
- But even if I put the right name,
I still wouldn't have got the point.
- Then-
- Oh yeah,
Garnt draws a house in the Kanji quiz.
- Oh, I don't remember this
one. The next Kanji is, house.
(lighthearted music)
- [Connor] All right,
I think I've got this.
- [Joey] All right, show it off.
- [Connor] All right.
- If you see this, you know what it means?
I stand by that, I stand.
If there, if I could
reinvent the Kanji system,
I mean, I would-
- Just be the house.
- Just be house, right?
Just be house.
Everyone knew what I meant,
everyone knew what I meant.
- [Joey] And then the last one is,
this one the-
- I love this one.
- [Joey] Oh, this is from
the meme quiz, right?
- No, no, no.
This is from the gaming quiz.
- Oh, the gaming quiz, the
gaming quiz, that's right.
Which video game did the meme,
"Press F to pay respects" come from?
- My fucking "Call of Duty"
knowledge is fucking awful.
- [Joey] Oh, it's "Call of Duty."
- You didn't know that?
- I said "Counter Strike Source."
(men laughing)
- See, okay.
This clip, there's one issue
of "Trash Taste After Dark,"
which is everything is live,
so we can't edit afterwards.
I remember seeing Joey's
face of panic when I said,
"Oh, it's "Call of Duty," guys,"
and Joey just goes.
"What?"
- Yeah, I was just like, "Uh."
- 'Cause that wasn't caught on camera
'cause the camera was on me,
but Joey just had like
the biggest face of panic
and it was like so funny.
- I was like, "Shit."
- That was very funny.
I love that moment.
- Yeah, that was very very funny.
- Wait, what do you think
is gonna win though?
It has to be "Nghaw," right?
- I want-
- I think actually I think it
might be the Budweiser one.
- I think it might be Budweiser,
because it's been nominated so much.
- Oh, true, true, true.
- Just 'cause it is an iconic moment.
- Nghaw is my personal favorite, but yeah.
- Nghaw is my personal favorite.
- I don't want nghaw to win.
I really don't.
- I kind of don't want Budweiser to win
because I don't want to
relive that moment anymore.
- A part of me would love to see
the "have to pay respect" one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- True, true.
- I don't think it will
win. But we'll find out.
What is this?
- Let's find out then.
All right, the dumbest quiz answer
of "Trash Taste After Dark" is,
Connor spells nghaw.
Well, you know what?
Well deserved, honestly.
- That was well deserved,
that was well deserved.
- That was well deserved.
I will never let you-
- Was it at least close?
- [Ashley] It was really close.
- Oh really?
- Ooh, ooh.
- [Ashley] That won
with 26.9% of the vote.
- Right.
- [Ashley] Joey's have to pay respects,
press F to pay respects
came in second with 26%.
- Oh wow.
- That came-
- That was really close.
- Less than a percent.
- Oh, I'm sad.
But I mean, I deserve it.
That was very, very dumb.
And I have no recourse for it.
That was just that, what it was.
- At least it was funny.
- At least it was a good moment.
- It was good, it was good.
- You made a good moment,
you made a good moment.
- All right, second to last.
What do got?
- And the second to last moment
is I guess just moment of the year.
- Moment of the year.
A single moment.
There were many moments of this year.
- It's just like one,
I guess it's like one
single snapshot of the year.
There's many, there's many great moments.
We've gone through a lot of them already.
I think a lot of them are too long
to be considered a moment.
They're very iconic pieces,
but here are the moments
that you guys voted for.
So it's Connor mumbles the
charity stream announcements.
- [Joey] Wait, play that one.
- [Garnt] Play the clip.
(Connor mumbling)
- [Connor] $250.
I'm the main protagonist,
think of the $10, 31.
(Connor mumbling)
Whispering, I think of the $5.
Noah, I think of the $10.
(mumbling) Thank you for the $10.
Deez nuts, thank you for the $20.
- [Garnt] All right, there.
We've seen this one already.
- [Joey] The lubed "Among Us."
- [Garnt] Lubed "Among Us."
- [Joey] Play that one.
- No.
- Oh no, oh no.
- Let me check if there's
tissue inside first.
(men laughing)
Why is it lubed?
Who lubed this?
Is this like a lubed "Among Us" thing?
It feels like "Among Us."
- I think if we had like
a quote of the year,
that would definitely win.
- Lubed "Among Us."
- Is that a lubed "Among Us?"
- Honestly, nothing else,
what surprised me is like,
even looking back I'm like,
how was I so sure about that?
But it was like the only
thing that came to my mind
as I was touching it.
I was like, it's lubed "Among Us."
'Cause I remember I was
just like, no other guesses.
It's lubed "Among Us."
Oh my God.
- [Joey] And then obviously
me smelling cat poo.
- [Garnt] Yeah, so we've seen that one.
- [Joey] Garnt decides
to rob a 12 year old.
Oh this from the TRPG.
- Oh, this one, yeah, yeah.
- That kid's like 12.
What's stopping us from taking.
- [Joey] From killing it?
Oh.
(people laughing)
- Yo, yo.
What if Mira distracts
the shopkeep by talking.
And then you.
- I go in and nick the-
- You go grab some potions.
Whatever you can, how about that?
- So just wondering.
- [Garnt] No murder, no murder needed.
- I love that title outta context.
- Yeah, that was just a
great scene in general.
If you're not into TTRPGs, nor was I,
but I really had a lot
of fun filming that.
And if you don't know the context,
we, the gang decides to
rob a 12 year old merchant.
- Naturally, as one does.
- Well, just like, we tried to rob,
Joey tried to murder him.
- Yeah, I was like, "Let's just kill him."
Just kill him.
And then Garnt spells quintessential.
- Quint-essential.
Oh fuck, if I have to spell essential.
Q-U-I-N-T.
- [Joey] Yeah?
E-S-S.
- Yes.
- E-N-T-I-A-N.
Was I, was I correct?
- [Joey] That's quintessentian.
- Oh fuck!
- I don't remember that.
Quintessentian.
- Quint, I don't, I literally
just got reminded of that.
- I realize all of these best
moments are from "After Dark."
- Yeah, I noticed that as well.
- Why is that not part of
the the dumbest answers one?
- Quintessentian.
- [Connor] What's the last one?
- [Joey] The answer is shagging sheep.
What's this one?
- [Ashley] In 1881,
parliament passed legislation
banning what in Wales?
- Shagging sheep.
(men laughing)
- [Ashley] The answer is, shagging sheep.
- Oh!
- [Ashley] Nah, nah, nah, I'm kidding.
It's not shagging sheep.
- Fuck!
(men laughing)
- That's very good.
- Oh my God.
I've never had like a fucking
boner taken outta me so fast.
- That was the most like Jebaited moment.
- Yeah, yeah, that was a
fucking Jebaited moment.
Yeah, I mean I'm surprised.
a lot of these moments,
I guess because they're like short moments
and they work the best in
like a live stream setting.
'Cause these are all
amazing fucking moments.
- I feel that's what "Trash
Taste After Dark" is though.
It's just a collection of
like short bursts of moments.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, right?
- We're chill as well.
I think we don't really like discuss much.
We just kind of have a fun time.
- It's a vibe.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's a vibe.
- I think that's why
there's so many on here.
- [Garnt] Fun games.
- All right well, let's
hear what the winner is.
- So the moment of the year,
this one I actually don't know.
- [Joey] I have no idea.
- They're all like fantastic moments.
- Budweiser.
It's gotta win something.
- I feel it's Budweiser.
- It's gotta win something.
- Come on, give it to Budweiser.
- The moment of the year goes to,
beer tasting Budweiser reveal.
- Yeah!
That was an iconic moment.
- I mean, considering how much
this was nominated and this,
I think this was like the
most nominated anything.
- All the American viewers
came together and was like,
"We gotta nominate this one."
- I mean, even like the
non-American views came together.
- It was good, it was very good.
- It was a great moment,
considering how much
we clowned on America.
It was the "Trash Taste"
instant karma moment.
- Well, what was the top three, Ashley?
- [Ashley] Top was Budweiser
reveal with 29.5% of the vote.
- Okay.
- [Ashley] In second
place was lubed "Among Us"
with 24.7% of the vote.
- Thank God.
So happy.
- There is the God.
- [Ashley] Slightly behind was
Garnt robbing a 12 year old
with 14.3% of the vote.
- I robbed a 12 year old?
We all did that, we all did that.
- It was your idea, Garnt.
- We did that.
- Yeah, it was your idea.
- Your idea.
- It was your idea to kill him, Joey.
We don't mention that, do we?
- We didn't go for that idea, now did we?
- I stopped you from doing that, Joey.
Why am I the bad guy here?
- All right, while Garnt was busy
deciding which kids to rob,
we are gonna read the final award.
- Oh shit.
- Final award.
- What's the final award, Connor?
- Of course, it's gotta be,
the best "Trash Taste"
episode of the year.
According to you, the viewers.
- 50 Whole episodes to choose from.
- Yeah, I don't know what it would be.
So let's have a look at
what the nominations are.
Episode 56 along with Chris.
Episode 65 that
"We cannot stop arguing."
- "We cannot stop arguing."
- Is that the food one?
- [Garnt] That was the chicken.
- That was the chicken
debate one, I believe.
- Hmm?
- [Mudan] That was like the self care.
- [Man] Oh yeah.
- No, I think this is
the chicken debate one.
- That's the chicken debate one.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Connor] The one with Jan.
Figure special, which came right after it.
- [Joey] Of course.
- [Connor] And then we also have.
- [Joey] Our worst foods takes.
- Which is the one where I
gone to eat the stuffed crust.
- Oh yeah, that's right.
- Yeah, yeah.
That was also the bread episode as well.
- [Joey] Oh, okay.
And then the only special
we had this year, so far.
And then we had, "We almost died,"
which is I think the
camping special, right?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Yeah, and then-
- Oh, the camping special.
- The camping special.
- Oh, the camping episode.
- [Garnt] Yeah, the camping,
the camping episode.
- And then the dream episode when.
- One where we had lucid dreams.
- Well let's talk about it.
- This says one of two.
Is this the second one?
- This is the second one.
We just saw the first one.
- Okay, okay.
- Garnt's dementia's
kicking in, of course.
- Well no, it says one of two.
- I know, but we saw it.
- He said it, yeah.
Oh man.
I mean, obviously, you know, for me,
the cooking special is special
because it's a special.
- Yeah.
Thank you very much for that, Joey.
- What one-
- Define special, Joey.
- I need to look up the
thesaurus real quick.
- I just got that, I just
didn't pay attention.
- What won the best episode last year?
- The hentai special.
- It was the hentai episode.
- The hentai episode.
- Naturally, okay.
- Yeah, the hentai episode.
- I don't want Chris' to win,
'cause I don't want to boost Chris's ego.
- True.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause he will not shut
the fuck up if he wins.
- True.
- Yeah.
- And you guys think
we're joking, we don't.
- I honestly personally
would probably vote
for the dream episode.
- Okay, so it's weird,
'cause I think one of my favorite to film
was the dream episode
because that was a conversation
I had with the boys
that I've kind of like never
had with anyone before.
It was just like such
a weird conversation.
And I, it was just such a self discovery
and such a discovery of like,
"Oh, not everyone dreams
the same way I do?"
I'm like, "What's going on?"
That was like so weird.
- [Joey] Definitely.
- Aside from that,
obviously the great
chicken debate was very,
very fun to film.
- Go back to the other slide again.
I mean the arguing on the figure special.
I mean there's a lot of contenders.
- Even the-
- These are all-
- Even the Jan episode was great.
- Honestly, these are all
fucking fantastic episodes.
- Yeah, and obviously
the way we chose these
is you guys basically said
which ones were your favorite?
So we decided, and then we opened voting.
So yeah, I guess, let's just see what its.
- All right.
- Let's end the awards, eh.
- Let's wrap it up, baby.
- All right.
- The best "Trash Taste" episode,
according to you guys from the last year,
or 50 episodes or however
the fucking long it's been.
- 2022.
- Yeah.
- Is,
the anime figure special.
- Oh.
- Ooh!
Okay, I wasn't expecting that.
- I mean, that was a very good episode.
- It was a very good episode.
- It was a great episode.
- Holy shit, because I forgot
this wasn't just the episode,
this was just like the build up.
- The MCU.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This was the TTMCU, basically.
That was so fun to film as well.
What I'm proud of this for
is that our individual,
if you compare our individual
videos to last year,
you could tell that we had leveled up.
- Oh absolutely.
- You know what I mean?
And that was obvious where we,
like all our videos
like doubled in length.
Hasn't it?
- Yeah, definitely, definitely.
And also not to mention,
this year we also had the
"After Dark" one as well, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So it's like a five parter.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was a lot to keep up with.
- I think, there's like nine
hours of footage all together.
- It was a lot, like it was a lot.
- Out of the five.
- Thank you very Mudan, for carrying that.
- That's right, editing
almost all of them.
- It turned out really good, you know?
- Yeah.
- I think, all the arguments
aside, it was a fan favorite.
I mean clearly, I mean they loved it.
And we had a lot of fun doing it.
Blood pressure was rising, but I think,
yeah, I understand why it was voted.
What were the results?
- Top three, what are the top three?
- [Ashley] Top three.
First place was the figure
episode with 22.3% of the vote.
- Wow, that's.
- [Ashley] Second place was
"100 ways to die in
Japan" with Chris Broad.
- Oh, thank God, thank God.
- [Ashley] With 20.3% of the vote.
- Thank God.
- [Ashley] And in third place
was the cooking special,
with 17.9% of of the vote.
- Nice.
- Nice nice, nice.
- Hell yeah.
- Good to know people
still like the specials.
- Yeah, thank God.
Thank God.
- Thank God, thanks, guys.
- Thank you very much.
Yeah, well I guess that's kind of like,
that's kind of a full
season two of "Trash Taste",
I guess, right?
Until like.
- Yeah, damn.
- How do you guys feel season two went
compared to like season one?
- I mean.
- Good.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, it was great.
- "Uh?"
- I mean, you know.
- It was okay, right?
- I think-
- I'm not gonna say it was mid, but.
- I think, you know, we could
have done more specials,
but it was a nightmare with moving
and getting everything
all set up and then.
- To be fair.
- And trying to get "After Dark" all done.
- That, yeah, I was about to say,
to be fair, you know,
I think because of the fact
that we really put our strengths
into "After Dark" this year, you know,
I feel that kind of led us away
from the specials a little bit.
But you know, I'm still
very proud of "After Dark."
You know?
- Yeah, of course, yeah.
- People are loving it.
- Shame we couldn't get
more guests on, really.
I would've liked to
have a few more guests.
- Definitely, definitely.
- Just like three or four
more guests to mix it up.
And it was just kind of unfortunate
where we couldn't really find anyone
and right timings when we did find people.
It was kind of like, and
then we had to bulk record.
It was kind of all.
- I mean,
we definitely thought the
borders were gonna open
by this second season, right?
But unfortunately it didn't, but.
- Yeah, I mean, I think we definitely,
I think one thing I would
always say about "Trash Taste"
is we always try to do something new
and something different,
and I would say season two
is definitely different from season one.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- And it might not have been
reflected in the main channel,
but it was definitely reflected
with everything we did outside
of the main channel as well.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause it wasn't just
like the studio move.
It was just, we really tried to,
we always tried to give
you the best content,
even if it's all, not
all put into one place.
I think the proudest
thing that I did this year
was definitely like the 24 hour stream.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- That was insane.
- Absolutely.
- Like one thing,
one massive, massive, massive difference
from season one and season two
is our team behind the cameras.
- Oh yeah.
- Because season one we had
Meilyne and we had Ashley.
And that, you know, that's all we had.
And then we couldn't have done
everything that we did in season two,
especially something
like the 24 hour stream,
without the massive-
- All the "After Dark" shows as well.
- All the "After Dark" shows.
- 'Cause the thing is like,
I would love to do more "After Dark,"
but logistically it's just so much harder
than main channel videos, right?
- Yeah, definitely.
- 'Cause we, with the main channel videos,
we can record that ahead of time.
You know, we can record whenever we want.
- Also, a lot more planning
goes into "After Dark"
then the regular episodes like that.
- Yeah, we just sit down
and talk here, you know?
Like we have to have
people like write quizzes,
plan what we're gonna do.
We have to schedule stuff.
There's a lot more work
that goes into "After Dark"
and we really hope you guys
have enjoyed "After Dark."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It will return when we're
back from traveling around
and you know, kind of going
to weddings and stuff.
- But in the meantime, like, hey,
subscribe to the channel.
- Yeah.
- Watch all the "After Dark" stuff.
There's plenty of good stuff there.
- Yeah, no one subscribes to "After Dark,"
but people watch a lot of it.
- People watch "After Dark,"
but no one subscribes.
- So please subscribe, please.
- Subscribe to "After Dark."
- What do you, is there anything you guys
are looking forward to in season three?
What do you guys want
out of the next year?
- I think we'll have more
guests than we've ever had.
- Yes.
- I think so.
- And I think, you know,
that we're gonna have more
specials than this year.
- Yes.
- Let's hope.
- I know for sure that
we're gonna have more.
- Yes.
- 'Cause we already have plans, so.
- Yeah.
- You'll get more specials
and hopefully we can
just make it all better.
- Yeah.
We will continue endeavoring
to push the envelope
with not just being a podcast channel.
- Just being a show.
- But just being a show.
all we want to do is make good content,
and we hope you guys can see that.
Whether that's on the main channel
or anything else we choose to do,
we're always gonna be
trying to push the envelope
to try and do something new.
And one thing, without
spoiling anything that we do
or anything that is coming up,
we're definitely gonna be using
more budget in season three.
- Hell yeah, let's go.
- Like a lot more budget.
- Big things are coming, definitely.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Big things are coming.
- So don't think that
you've reached the end of "Trash Taste".
We have a lot, a lot of
exciting things coming up.
- It's just the beginning, baby.
- This is, it's always just the beginning.
- It's only 100 episodes, baby.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 100 more to go.
- So yeah, I guess thank you to you guys.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- For continuing to supporting us.
- Thank you so much.
- Like it's,
I didn't think that we
would get to 100 episodes.
- I think we've all been blown away
by just like the insane amount of support
and the fact that everyone's
been sticking around.
I think 100 episodes is a lot to ask.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- It's a lot for a podcast, as well.
- Right?
But it's, you know, I
think reading the Reddit,
seeing the tweets, people
just saying, you know,
how much "Trash Taste" means to them,
I think that really reinforces
why we're doing this
and why we enjoy doing it
other than the bank, of course.
I'm kidding.
But no, I really do appreciate it
and I think we all really,
really appreciate the support
and how much "Trash Taste"
means to some of you guys.
And we hope we can make more memes,
more moments and more
memorable bits for you guys
to just have fun with.
- Yeah, shout out to the fans,
shout out to the Redditors,
shout out to the staff
and shout out to the boys.
- Yeah.
- That's all it is.
- Thank you very much, Joe,
for shouting us out.
- Thanks man, thanks man.
I needed that, I needed that.
- I need to shout out the boys.
- Well done, guys. Well
done, well done, well done.
- Can't do it without the boys.
Can't do it without the boys.
- Thank you.
- Well done.
- Exactly.
- Unfortunately not all
the staff here are today,
but otherwise I would like to get them
all to come on camera,
because we have a pretty
massive crew right now.
- A lot.
We got a lot, yeah.
- Yes.
- But yeah, I guess that's,
that's kind of it, right?
- That's it.
- I know it feels lonely.
- We'll see you guys in
episode 101, I guess.
- We have to pretend
like we didn't do this.
- It's the start of a new era.
Start of a new era, but
hey, in the meantime though,
look at these lovely patrons.
- Look at these lovely patrons.
- These guys are the goats right here.
- They are indeed.
- Supporting the show.
And hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
hopefully the next 100 episodes
and more of "Trash Taste,"
then follow us on Patreon.
Patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us your memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah.
- Yeah.
- See you guys in season three?
- Is it?
- I guess.
- Is that what we're calling it?
- I don't know.
See you guys for another 50 episodes,
and we'll be celebrating it all the same
in the "Trash Taste Awards"
part three, I guess.
- Yep.
- See you there, boys.
- We'll see then.
- [All] Bye!
(smooth music)